and we are back and the match is going
to get underway in just a few minutes
from now we want to remind everybody of
the bracket who's playing how they have
done thus far this is the fifth match of
the opening round of the I am not GM
speed chess championship as you can see
here the one two three and five seats no
upsets according to initial seating
vivid question for you we have this
matchup ahead of us between le pates and
air rosin the six verse T 11 does the
underdog by seed win is that air of
rosin or do we see le picks justify her
seeding and defeat Eric Rosen this match
I've seen le play in many of the over
the board tournaments and I know that
she's a very strong player I've seen
like many 27 hundreds like struggle to
win against her so I know that she can
be very tough opponent to beat and not
see much from Eric to be honest but I've
seen him play like stream a lot so I'm
sure he has that advantage now it will
be like a perfect clash like this
practice a lot L or euro this board
skills metamour so it's a perfect day to
find out yeah actually this one is a
pretty interesting toss up by ratings
online because le pitch is the higher
rated than two in classical chess by far
but Eric as you said better bullet
player yeah le is probably better in
blitz but you know it's gonna come down
as we see the format here 75 minutes of
the 5-minute 45 minutes of 3 + 1 and
finally 25 mil minutes a bullet with
that 1 second increment I think that
makes a huge difference between regular
bullet when you are just down to the
wire you lose on time having that second
increment is pretty big
especially for players who are not so
experienced in the online format so I do
believe that increment helps le pates it
tends to help the higher rated player
over the board and so that I do think
that should increase her chances as we
get into its speedy situations but our
daily question and you're gonna have to
answer this as well get involved with
hashtag speech as to all our viewers
does streaming while playing chess have
a negative or positive effect on your
speed chess skill so vidi you are
becoming a very popular streamer you
just
started and have a lot of viewers you
beat the heck out of me in our bullet
match so you could save your answer for
later or you can just give it now what
do you think about the impact story lies
in your chin you when you ask for that
it reduces its impact there so I'll
spare you today
but I do I think for me from my
experience for the last week like when I
started out it was very tough for me to
like you know look at the chat the stalk
and play but I got the hang of it like
once I did it like two or three sessions
and then I started to enjoy it you know
because winglets you're interacting with
the audience and they're like you know
supporting you it feels awesome to be
honest so for me the answer is I don't
think it has had any negative impact so
far it's just positive for me so it's
small sentiment for the win small sample
size you did win title Tuesday or sorry
you got second second yeah but eight out
of nine is a phenomenal performance and
you were saying that you know usually
from slightly below that so clearly the
streaming paid off in this case and
playing me in bullet I think if we were
off camera and you know just duking it
out I don't think you'd have that kind
of score against me yes also like I
usually play well in Mike and Jo
someplace where you know there are so
many people watching you so it kind of I
think I'm that kind of person what about
you do you think it helps I don't think
it helps me I you know I know you focus
too much on the test and then you forget
about chess I do because I'm the full
commentator so I look at this board I'm
looking at this close Sicilian structure
here and then I just think about how I
can explain that to the viewers the next
thing I know I have 12 seconds left and
about to lose on time but then we have
this opening in this first game here I
tend to like the closest one from the
white side I know I have bias because I
grew up playing to close this on but
especially in these kind of variations
where black is delayed the King movement
you can still Castle queenside it's a
bit risky but castling King side is well
h3g for ideas Knight to g3 to follow
what do you think when you see a
position like this I like black like
I've been a Sicilian player since my
childhood and I always believed in
Blacks counterplay but I know
there are people like who just play G
for anyone would just throw the pieces
you know and it's a good skill in h5o
you didn't like that move I can tell by
your tone no I didn't expect it actually
it looks cool it looks cool I like all
cool moves even if it doesn't work I
like it just for the record yeah and it
takes away the g4 option that expansion
that white wants to have happened here
but it does loosen the g6 square for
instance that may seem like Robert what
are you talking about g6 is hard to get
to but if I am able to get f5 and
capture on e6 then the g6 square is a
little bit loose so those are the
long-term things you consider here and
then let me ask you is that black came
going Queen side now because he played
h5 not so you see that like I would yeah
you big break with c3 d4 and all kinds
of stuff yeah and their fears King is
really safe on yet where it is right now
okay just like I wouldn't dare to go
long battle immediately at least I would
wait until you know this for the action
yeah especially have to c3 because
you're always considering capturing on
b4 verb c1 things like that and I like
what Elly is doing here but plays live
you give the bishop a new diagonal to
work with Bishop a6 but then you want to
think about c4 for white because if that
Bishop leaves the ah-1 long diagonal at
some moment c4 can be a consideration
not yet you're losing upon but rook c1
c4 type of break and then you're both
sides are jockeying for a real plan
because the position is so close no
piece of the trade and the best thing
about it is like the speed with which
keeps playing yes he's playing fast I
like that and when I spoke to when we
spoke to her it seemed like she was very
in a casual mood you know and that is
good for billets actually if you're
super focused you kind of like get low
on time when you're just like having fun
and you know like you have the right
balance it's really although I don't
understand Quinn b7 looks weird to put
the Queen on the diagonal of g2 a h18
yeah it does but she shined it at some
point caps on c3 and take over the B
file so I would just play c4 you know
like you should be considered you have
to consider but what if I just take it
what if I get greedy and say let me
steal your pawn on c4 are you gonna be
able to take advantage of this
quickly enough or have you given me a
pawn or hoping for some kind of
compensation okay doesn't matter oopsie
one plate like that doesn't matter but
she goes I'm going for the endgame and
now she for sure is canceling keys on
Queen D woman oh you trying to trap this
Queen yeah and your son is a trip so I
can't really do much so Queen b3 what if
I just can't run a trade oopsie two
books it to Brooke c2 a bit ambitious in
yeah because Roxy do you give up control
the B file forever all this Castle
kingside and I guess you'll go to g4 and
tried to meet me at some point but it's
a mixed bag of affairs and at that point
that's going between this d3 pawn is
such an annoying weakness for white
because you always even even eye on it
with this Bishop on a6 would you do beat
over do you lose it - I would yeah I
don't really want to repeat because you
know it feels it's early in the match of
the white pieces you wanna do something
he has known Queen d2 maybe and but
Queen no need T it looks good but you
can do it that's true you can hide on e3
actually I don't think Elly will repeat
here because her queen is improved from
b7 to b5 for ambitious f5 at some point
followed by Knight f4 jump it's getting
very aggressive for white here very
interesting game and must add mint so
far bishop g3 probably just to protect
e5 and then go for the five or just go
ahead directly what do you think it's
too much
no I you think only five yeah that's
what I'm thinking about right I take on
e5 and d3 is under attack and g4 is
under a shiny plate
yes yeah just sausage the g3 is making
sure that you're not hanging anything
queen bee - now yeah so your queen III
the black I would get nervous at this
moment right like f5 is very annoying
and this wine is also attacked I really
don't know what's happening and wine is
full control over the kings and look at
this configuration of piece is two
Knights and the bishops here with these
menacing pawns and black only has one
rook on the H file that stare into thin
air and rook C to be one as you're
pointing
threatens the trap disk we not be - it's
no safe squares and she repeats with
Queen to b3 why is Eric avoiding Queen
d2 into e3 I believe Queen e3 that movie
you suggested a while ago video it's
just a good one like you might be afraid
of some default but you also look we
need for and stuff like that right so
just axis knight on c6 and helps f5
become even more potent of a threat all
right at least like black should click
quicker so that you ask questions
because I don't think black can play for
more at the in the current situation
because f5 is a very strong right now
you know Queenie please forgive very not
good of them rejecting the trolls and
for an Eric this is very strong play in
kind of old-school Soviet technique
always repeat once right like that's
what they say it's a he
I had a friend you must be knowing
Grandmaster she Cuban he used to just
say that you should always repeat once
or twice in order to show who is the
boss and of course I know he beat me in
the last round of Isle of Man thank you
for bringing up some of my not so happy
memories you're such a good friend to me
but d4 played and I think that le
recognizes she needs some kind of
counter play because F I will be so
strong and she's freed up the be
Foursquare for her night
so after Queenie for now there's night
to be for so maybe capturing on d4 was
actually mistake by Eric he should have
played Queenie form yet because they're
going on on c3 and Appanna c5 c3 pawn to
e4 tonight's advice I don't know
well the c6 doesn't it like trap oh
you're getting feisty but next b7 okay
so you missing something no I'm just
Ryung to figure it out because night c5
I either take on c6 but even each unite
there is hanging no c5 Bishop c5 and
guru c1 that's what I was about to say
is that I could take on c5 big Queen
takes a 1 check with an Brooke c1 back
and then yeah I was hoping in the end
and then Queen c6 there's that's but
their Queen takes a 6 and actually
White's that up to my own
gets to yakking it's to in the end
awesome
oh that maybe I don't mrs. Rooke hhx oh
it's getting really complex here and I
think Elly has to go for things like
this because otherwise her position
collapsed with f5 so Eric thinking here
he has Queen takes his six where she
plays Bishop d7 doesn't trap the Queen
there's Queen c7 with any solution
what's happening
Lennox well repeaters coming yeah so
lucky one I suppose you get rid of that
but then Queen d3 simply queen Sizzix
was mistake I think you should have gone
to c5 rooks if I ships if I book c1 and
that was the way because here black has
the moves are easy oh wait repeats you
now and it looks loves to me just
repetition Bishop p7 also is interesting
but then there's handshakes just it's
just handshakes immediately after a
repeater yeah 9423 and take on g3 and I
wish and III check and it's just lost
yep you're right they both have such
poker face I don't really get it like
she takes a c5 my now the key one now
one oh that's a really nice in-between
move hitting this Queen on YouTube and
taking with the e3 Square even their
queen takes d3 with Ruby 2 to follow
still feels like Black has an initiative
but you're absolutely right that this
gives white a way out I think that both
knees should be too
because it wasn't hard maybe it was just
over on this part here yeah as far as I
can see yeah and now you want there is
played with 30 seconds like big time
advantage for Elly like one minute so
what do you do I would go Quincy to you
know keep this Ruby to thing alive oh
that's a good move because of Queen
takes bishop on e6 repeats who happens
and then there's a problem the g2 but
where you know to be sure have fun I
don't see meat I don't see made either I
was actually wondering the same thing
usually I don't see meat so I don't
trust
my skills you have missed so many
checkmates in one that's true we live
well okay going for some kind of attack
here but is that five a good move
can I ignore it right after f6 check ago
King g8 it's not made immediately I'm
actually quite safe back there so if I
would go Bishop d7 you know f6 King g8
Queen c7 Bishop f3 win beating at 7 like
attack both on g2 and be it yep if it
makes any sense makes perfect sense to
me
g f6 check happening in g8 Queen c7 be
sure whether you take take the bishop
you take the bishop back yeah you have
to so bitter of three bitter of three
and then some kind of rook be one ish
stuff oh one is very nice nice move
yeah yeah you just take away the ring
under attack all four seconds three
seconds doe he takes rook e1 he's being
slow he hasn't warmed up he got a girl
he won I don't see any other move yes
don't be one because what white really
needs to do is somehow get this check on
the O afraid is so not the move but I
think she's still be better you know
queen bee yeah yeah I mean two seconds
it's impossible to play so Queen a
treaties in Lodi Luke if it is very
practical in a way to just keep the king
safe yeah I understand what should be
one before specially for takes g6
you have to go for something like that
oh what's going on now Queen III ok 5800
finish for okay now it should be made g5
nice move for which Italy we made me I
don't see the main afore win a photo
catch - I just exchanged your pieces I
need it I knew a critics of fate why
don't we yeah when you have a queen if a
cutie for everyone's knee over towards
being one but you always need one oh
there's queen of what me too - me too
but it's completely winning but they
look like I'm lying it's like okay okay
now it's just lost but it's time why is
she playing so school that was in honor
of you visit missing multiple checkmates
in one we're gonna pull up that analysis
board really quickly just to show
everybody what we were talking about
some nice tactics there by le page in a
flirty because she fended off what
looked like a potential attack for Eric
Rosen Queen takes f8 check was about to
be devastating and the reason why is if
I make some random move Queen f8 King f8
rook c8 is checkmate on the back rank so
instead of allowing that she plays this
move rook e1 check King to d3 mister D 1
check the bishop in she takes it Kimmy
did you a mrs. Rooke d1 checkmate but it
didn't matter
she won the game anyway missing a second
checkmate in one still didn't matter
because she just traded and won the
games let's go to the live position we
have any if every game is going to be
like the first game I think I should
just get popcorn because it's so much
fun to watch just very entertaining yep
it is and le pates takes a 100 lead in
this match
so that was a crazy end to what was a
very interesting game I think we were
both impressed by what was happening
there and le pates good start for 96
Jesse 6 for town I will say that there
is compensation you know have you
noticed that eric has such a poker face
it doesn't look like he has blundered in
action look at them
he didn't shake his head a little bit
okay I missed it probably I mean he was
just like ah you know how could I
blunder that but it's gonna save it it
is there is some compensation here for
black because your pieces are so
accurate the mission 105 is good the
knight on c4 it's a tough decision for
white for sure you have compensation but
not enough for sure like you go Quincy
193 and yeah way to end in my point
about how you
tried that finally the nice trap that
MBA so night takes b2 was possible there
no but Queen b3 a 96 96 ah
darn you ruined my hopes and dreams
okay so b3 plate what a night a3 there
wait a sec night a 3 B 1 C 2 square
Brooke c1 but that night can be annoying
from that a 3 square I'm not saying okay
go what you know black is not doing well
we both know that but there is some
compensation here I'm still not thinking
this one's over just yet
- I mean like I think black should keep
fighting even if he's exchanged down if
it gets rope down you should keep
fighting you never know what will happen
well I think about this position let me
ask you how does white make progress
today book c1 but Brooke c1 there might
be some kind of beef or stuff 0:03
know everybody is the worst possible so
this movie Bishop rook takes c3 is the
tactic what's happening rook c1 rook
takes c3 doesn't mean you could even
take Roxy 3 you could have gone up
safely immediately as I think f3 was
such bad move why would it lift me you
want to go rutila and defend the pawns
I'm totally with you village because
this problem the diagonal is it's not
that rock takes c3 will work right away
Brooke c1 rook takes you 3 does not work
as I was shining because when I take
back on c3 I can block on what just
Bishop takes b1 I don't know what's
going on here I think Elly I don't like
what she has done so far not at all ok
and now we did the thing of it should be
3 was a threat so 91 may not be as bad
as it looks but before now yeah g1 okay
so I think white is still better I would
say yes I would go as far as to say that
oh I completely agree with that but it
feels like black has received more than
he deserved considering he just hung in
exchange for free oh sure and it's what
I was saying to you you were so certain
that all this is terrible so I agreed
with you
but the position wasn't so easy yeah I
know what do undo your
you're right yo guys I just want to
thank all of my fans for supporting me
as I made the push have it admit that I
was right okay but white is still doing
extremely well here Queen before is a
very good move you third a fourth
because the point B 5 is pin but also
just Queen a c5 gaining momentum on the
Queen side yeah if you have to go back
Luke see it okay it's it's a sign that
you know nothing's going your way
yeah 97 now I would play yeah covered
this a 5/5 and 85 is actually an idea
for Vlad yeah as b5 is protected so 97
is a good move rook c2 is meant by an a5
like push I would just flicking each one
get the King out of that pin
first and foremost I have an a5 for
black just did you yeah it's not super
black as compensation obesity even
vaccines rook c8 yeah Queen d3 is really
smart you're encouraging my broker to a
place where you can trade it that's very
smart after 91 she has played
impressively I would say yes very
accurately and so now we're in a
position where it's one pawn in the
night for Brooke and white should
probably overlook c2 c1 this is exactly
what she's doing and it should probably
be just decisive in White's favor so I
was going to ask you've it it and I
don't see the answer to this that's one
to say this your way how can black
continue to try to have some sort of
counter play here that's a good question
but hard to answer because I would
really like to attack d4 and for that I
need to get the Knight to c6 so I tied
down one route to the d5 but I'm just a
tempo short
so this Queen c3 was very clever he goes
h5 I'm like agh night of five yeah
that's a very smart move exactly what
you were saying I need to attack d4 and
this apology for has been very annoying
for lot to deal with
it's the double pawns but takes away the
idol score Oh giving the e4 square
Bishop d3 Queen a4 baby as well
a queen of forea queen of four makes
sense but Knight a5 it's not so clear
anymore
but we don't see it it should be winning
yeah because the b54 you know queen a
food I would be five let's push him
alright Yaser goose Rafi
pushing baby you're right though you
five is the move you have to play just
start coming up with some counter play
for black so what should white do here
it should be should you suggest that
we're suggesting all animals and I'm
suggesting all these moves and so far
that's working out well for Elly she is
a one to nothing but in this game Eric
has achieved counter play out of nowhere
so II 500 no he's five the boat don't
see it gosh okay yeah that wasn't good
that was in treaties yeah sometimes you
just have a moment where you put a piece
on a square and you're like her reaction
was very unhappy obviously because what
am i doing I was up in exchange I'm very
early in this game huh it's a sign offer
you know not like being shot hanging a
piece like that I did it when I come
back to chess after long time like
playing chess when I play after like two
weeks or something after I come back
from my hibernation and I start playing
I hang up pieces so wait thanks going on
King at two Edie
he wants a sibling for the cloud no but
King 863 you know yeah and I just have
Queen a Friday night afford neither
phone please Oh another fun that is so
nice enough one to follow that's very
clever
oh it's very clever but that's nice fine
did it oh he did it yep this this weighs
even better because you keep the Queen's
on the board it's a weak King three to
the Queen c7 I would lick win ce7 for
like I'm a show-off so I would do it in
season yeah that was a nice fine though
so Eric Rosen
he rebounds from his game one debacle
where did feel like White had the
advantage and that
before suddenly le turn on the Jets and
was able to take that full point so it's
it felt like a role reversal where I
think in the first game you can correct
me if I'm wrong vivid we liked um Eric's
position with the white side behind of
losing this game of course we loved L DS
position from the white side she's up in
exchange and now she's lost this game
after some stubborn defense by both
players yeah nothing to add I mean I'm
just shocked why this Bishop f5 like if
you play Bishop a5 you kind of like give
up on the game yeah I mean now I would
just resign with white why would you
even continue just doesn't make sense
yeah there's Queenie okay resignation
Queen Anne shook when she almost
checkmate and sometimes you just need a
breather you need to finish the game so
that way when you start the new game you
have a clean slate and Ellie goes for
the d6 Bishop e7 this team keto and
what's this opening called by living
don't ask me I don't know why why are
you I put me on the spot when I don't
know openings because you play all kinds
of stuff like this like a six g6 b6 I
don't know the names of it okay we don't
put labels on things here good it this
is just you know it's just the b6 Bishop
d7 duration and the reason why Ellie
enjoys us in there offbeat not really
main line theory the lumpy sevens
on a very strong diagonal keeping the
bishop on f1 stuck for the time being
which means we move like f3 can be
played but if you're white in this
position you sort of want to put h3g for
rook to G 1 of course before doing that
and put your lon d3 lining up
against the black King and so castling
queenside is very doable but you have to
do it quickly because it sometimes black
gets a quick strike instead of an e 5
coming and then even an e4 I usually in
my childhood I used to really like such
portions with black very easy to play
yep lui 5 and I love the bishop on b7
long Castle nice yep here comes ee5 they
might be prompt down the D file you have
to be very careful when there's a rook
staring down the same line is a queen I
think II five was playable there but
then you also lose in your protection of
the F five point e so e 5 584 is one of
those ideas that sound very good
space but when your opponent has a pair
of Bishops you also opening up diagonals
and in particular this bishop on f4
would achieve more space in those cases
Bishop g5 now makes sense
people like yeah you have to worry for
and not six glad six white one move away
from playing g4 so h6 is a very good
move to make that much harder you have
to take on f6 probably ooh
c5 yeah g4 I want to play g4 yeah let's
go let's go to fourth why not
G I would add G 464 ETD force because d3
is coming in White's position to be
honest
no because rook C and now that doesn't
come quickly enough d4 so well protected
by White's pieces and if I can collapse
your pawn chain
even though GTA v not at the end of the
world I would go F for Bishop f4 95 oh
look at you with more tactics here you
can't even well you can't take on d5 but
yeah it'll get 4 and I get like a lot of
counter play f2 is hanging Group C it is
in the air and yeah you know I get wound
up oh yeah I like that
going very aggressive here suppose rook
c8 instead she won't just be 5 but
doesn't seem like it's with the same you
know potency like be 5 d same idea right
v be one just picking b1 i
wouldn't even play king b-rabbit rook g3
here because rookie 3 stops anything
from the coming to c3 square and I'm
gonna go from D to G 1 there should be
h6 for cage 70 that seemed a little
strange to me yeah I don't like Bishop
at 6 because you give King h8 and you
have to move the bishop so why would he
go bishop at 6 it's like that one more
trick and the claim might be the work on
f7 is misplaced but I actually don't
believe it is as the rook wasn't going
to come over the C file anyway I don't
believe
we won okay can be one your idea makes
perfect Sandia looking a chipped yeah
so you kind of wasted a move you should
not have gone bishop at six the claim
might be this rook an f7 is not great
but yeah I think this p5 is not a
can't even take it
exactly miss please blip that and wears
whites attack going to come from but the
thing is the rook could have been on g3
for white and another row could be
sliding to g1 with the King on g8
c-stick doubles yeah yeah that's not the
optimal play here and we'll see clear c3
is coming with a three pawn a weakness
and Elly's again upon dying a minute
advantage she's playing faster than
Eddie so far yes this building this
match has been so different from the
match we did yesterday for example
between Una's at on ski and Gretchen
hottie that match was very strategic in
nature this match has already been very
tactical so these players are warming up
but they haven't had much time to do so
and had they have tactical affair after
tactical affair mm-hmm so what do you
would you play as well your route g3
still comes to mind just covering the c3
school absolutely took one minute on
that by the way let's see I don't like
that move either what would you play EG
and go c3 and that's what I'm thinking
but III night f1c 3 min just 96 III I
know you're gonna take on b2 but I just
take a big one b2 and at six
yeah I'm not you know it's I just go
with intuition you I would try to I
attack as easy yeah but I could also
take 1 X 3 like you play c3 now you see
and then take on f3 and in the end take
Queen III if you want to play technical
yeah I see what you're saying then 95
type of stuff happens when Bishop e 94
comes in after takes a this is too crazy
there's some crazy stuff where both
sides of a bunch see there's a goodnight
thanks and know if maybe I'm sure back
soon know why why is he thinking I don't
know maybe think about Knight takes e4
or something but that doesn't look good
but vidit even if you go b takes c3 here
maybe just queen takes a three right
away 90 support I was afraid off 96 for
oh nice move alright that's a noob you
you find those every now and then
gosh vid it I I mix lucky I make living
from chess oh here comes Knight c4 that
training you had today clearly is paying
off you know you're you're in day I have
training today what I did teeny is not
what you told me that your tray I mean I
I didn't think I was like revealing a
big secret that I should you know regret
talking about you tell me you're gonna
work on chess today so yeah it feels
like you've worked on your chest finding
moves like Knight to c4 I hear in the
chat that Daniel was doing my
impressions really remember he was
telling a lot of bad puns that what they
mean okay whose puns a better I know I
haven't heard Daniel spawns and I can
imagine
Danny spawns and you know my points oh
no I'm not getting involved with this
I'm just like they say and you know
girls just want to have fun I just want
to have fun so it just things happen f4
f4 lady wore it to go to 95 I like that
that looks very dangerous maybe there's
Bishop d5 kind of stuff but f4 that's a
good move you really are just making 95
but he's so slow forty seconds yes years
to move faster
but he's a good bullet player so maybe
we should think that this is a critical
moment but I really what else to do
are you yeah I don't see her move upward
from before well I wasn't expecting that
one yeah why would he want him to really
give up that yeah that was a bit strange
because now f5 is also weak so f4 I can
use for Brook takes f5 or play for you
at some I guess he wants to play a fee
Bishop b4 Bishop d3 look c4b Chevy Ford
and what's happening we need three
madness is happening that's still got a
G file attack but it looks like white is
going down I mean Black's titles much
quicker that was some strange
decision-making here and Eric is far 205
seconds to just allow something like
this and you're right it's the time
management key you might not be used to
five-minute chats where you think that
you have more time than you really do
you could just take on d3 and go Roxy
six and I think it's just lost oh yeah
zero one I like that that's actually
simplest take yeah he takes rook c6 and
here it comes
you get this difference in speed whether
she's think much faster all trying to
Queen f7 mmm
but 92 looks exciting finish she's gonna
take on at five then I'd be to look at
five blacks up a pawns safer K yeah yeah
for sure it's better and then look f3 is
coming Oh what is rook a six or threat
no indeed there's d5 did that be five
this is something that I've noticed thus
far did it is that in her pony Oh taking
that pawn that bet seemed scared me but
inner points time trouble she's still
playing tactically and trying to play
quickly sometimes you just need to take
your time and finish the game by
whatever means necessary not just
sacrificing and getting aggressive but
it does look like it's going to work out
for her because King on a1 is so
vulnerable and why King a one and not
king c1 I'm not sure but here's that
much time think about it
ya know my native city and just Queen e5
and resigns yep
when it fires perfect and then rook
takes b3 - yeah or 95 maybe just YY even
Ruby - we do is like allowing him to
breathe 95 is like choking him yep and
you're the bully Corey for the bad
images which I put yeah yeah it's a way
of saying people are saying no Eric
there are some arrows and fans there who
are not happy that it looks like he's
losing H 5 is good given a king more
space than age 6 foot and OKC for you're
just down a queen and a night for two
rows a queen for two rooks in this
position would be interesting but with
the extra night for black it should just
be a kind of meeting exact kind of time
difference and so much yeah take T for
just don't the you know yeah exactly why
I didn't want to allow all this I don't
like
why should I calculate when I could just
finish it off some people enjoy
calculating that it's part of chess it's
not all I don't I don't
I am the I'm Lizzy I don't believe that
not one bit which of the many winning
moves did you play might be for here
yeah yeah a night before it's after
night before I play c6 there it is just
you got to have that passed font start
running only tonight mmm Oh see now
you're to thinking you're like night I'm
not sure where the night goes yeah
exactly and absolutely Queen on c7
yeah Queen if I Quincy Sun and breeze
Aires and then just resigns like five
times but it's not happening that's what
I keep telling you stop saying resigns
you should have learned by now rookie to
just play in a fight Queenie v 1 v 2 v
indeed still turning yes Queen d88
okay now now design please no
resignation for you vid it okay no
resignation coming your way like we did
not do that
well because you want to waste some I
think of your air bros and you really do
want to waste time off the mass clock oh
my god still me that's why you know
resigned that was still me oh my gosh
oh my instant replay didn't we have to
pull the analysis board did you see that
coming
no I was I thought like the game is
finished I was reading the chat and then
your statement I just like relaxed
because she showed it Queen seven check
King ke and if your pre moving G to here
which seems of in what happened after G
to the King can't move that is an
ingenious trap set by Eric Rosen and now
it's a one and a half one half tie
instead of a two-to-one deficit
oh my gosh video you speechless ya say I
mean have you learned your lesson ah I'm
frustrated yeah I'm so frustrated
it pains me it pains me to just say say
everyone was here come on say it
say we're always saying I'll put my ear
close say no okay you're right okay just
checking
there you get it said nobody pains me to
see a statement like this it's very
painful very painful well no pain no
game is what they save it and
unfortunately for Ellie
Bates she suffers a draw in a completely
winning position because of approvals
but it happens this is speech s this is
the drama that the people have requested
no come on man
come on bid it I'm going I'm recovering
man you're okay you're okay
really like I feel so bad I don't know
why I mean I feel as if it's my own game
I feel like that when something like
this happens I mean like say I don't
know okay so I just don't know what to
tell you right now
what did an Australian chess player tell
another Australian chess player when
they walked out of McDonald's angrily
I don't get it
no they walked out of McDonald's angrily
what did they say I'm hating it I don't
know no it's stalemate oh that is so bad
but it's so clickable that I hate is
that one of your friends jokes did you
come up with that one
no I saw the statement and I had to make
it even worse like I'm healing you know
I'm trying to heal myself but it's not
working
oh gosh you are you're a healer you are
just you're the person the people needed
and they didn't know they needed but
right now we have more chests h4 I'm
worried
about Ellie here because when you lose
half a point in a position you're
completely winning in you feel the urge
to like win the next game like win at
all cost
and Eric seems first on the queenside
before Ellie can get anything going on
the kingside you know you want to play
with like h5 or something like this but
it does feel like black holds all the
cards here yeah I like blacks position
and Eric down a minute on the clock
that's been slow yeah I would just you
know take on c3 or go 97 I would like to
bring the Knight to d6 and open up the
c5 put the hooks on C file logical chess
he finds my life I don't know if I like
that move actually but it makes sense
you cannot take on d5 Knight f3 what oh
no this is a major tilt tilt we have an
idea rook deep take rook e1 Queen B -
and then rook d7 and then you're fond of
sevens in some trouble
uh-huh but uh huh good night you're not
good but I can play Queen c3 I'm not
afraid of you you should be more afraid
of me show me some respect with it
because I'm with you just in general
when you win a piece for free you don't
want to see your opponent get counter
play like does a complete blunder but
yeah there there is an attacking chance
here because the black king is not very
sociable so cuz Queen a7 thought my
rookie six and all of a sudden your king
is getting in harm's way
sure me afraid I think I did okay fate
because it matches any played Queen b3 I
totally missed that much better move and
kudos to him for finding that I missed
it I didn't even see a good move I was
so focused on maybe she is a semblance
of Hope with some attacking chances and
then you play Queen b3 they're like okay
there goes any hope of my attack I
should just resign and go to the next
game but this is when tilt happens we
are watching tilt
she was completely winning against air
Rosa and game
he somehow worked his way into a
stalemate and now 4le pets she's hoping
that hey rookie for were caged for comes
at a timely manner and I can checkmate
the King actually working for here
there's Ruby for just to keep yourself
safe but King JSON c-3po catch one yeah
I know I know you move ahead that's how
you should go to Kiev oh how do you stop
this also Ruby one is a threat to in
some variations to distract your Queen
which means a protect f7
so what she a clear way he's six is
risky oh this is not so easy thing to do
Never Say Never well you've learned you
have clearly learned I'm so proud of you
I knew it I knew it
like I'm so proud you just hit me with a
Justin Bieber song and you also have
learned to never resign I am very proud
of you
I became a believeth oh yes you did you
saw my face and then you became a
believer and stuck button yeah
Queen age six rock age one um I'm sorry
but what's going on here vidit help me
out
is this just check me I don't see how to
defend I guess Queen c-44 is one way of
trying I think it's uncomfortable I can
see is moving in his chair it doesn't
see how I felt okay I think we stay for
maybe one Quinby one
no no Queen wants to crazy okay Quincy
for Quincy for Brooke h1 Queenie for ya
Jaipur you kicked the King away from the
into the h-file because any King the
first doesn't work no king of seven when
it's an King of six it looks at least
interesting I'm not sure if it's working
it's not working so you're right so
we're gonna take you seven I would play
Queen see what is so but it was Queen
effort yeah that's it
unnecessary pawn to capture its kind of
adding insult to injury you've already
won a piece because your opponent
blundered and now you're stealing this
pawn that's meaningless to the actual
position but you can get away Brooke
East six I like the idea
there's so many threats here but pretty
much every move that brings your queen
to safety should help out no Queen
GeForce ever moved there it is and I
would just I don't know what to say that
it Rick f6 all right it makes sense cool
tweeting hey sadly fight free rocks
I like does yum-yummy
Wow yeah we do you talk about McDonald's
which does not sound yummy at all but I
just have to hit you back with a little
bit of taste
hey biddat yeah well I got something to
tell you man I'm worried but that'd be
good you know worried about le pates
here I'm really worried didn't didn't
would ya tilt is very real so I kind of
feel like she needs to win this game for
her own morale just so that she can go
back to an even score but thus far in
the match it does feel like Eric Rosen
is making the most of his chances and le
on her side she's just kind of she's
wavering she's not she's moving quickly
but she's let him escape in that game
when she's stabbing him when she totally
outplayed him and then she's no peace
the only thing which helps in such
situation is either you had a good pun
or you win a game well she has a funny
game and I have you exactly the
stalemate one was pretty good I have to
admit that was pretty good the timing
was good
hey what you can't hear it so it's not
helping but I can hear it so it's
helping me which helps everybody who's
watching this broadcast and we have
another closed Sicilian setup here in
this case black has the two bishops then
efficient one b3 was captured Queen h4
doesn't really look super powerful but
you can't castle with a 97 under attack
f5 the matter what ever notice that
linking tactics Eric has been better yep
but the positions like you know le so
far I think she is playing better like
positionally or strategically if I can
say that but tactically is so tricky I
agree he's been very resourceful and
even in the last position he plays King
he he knows the tricks of the trade and
that's essential when you're playing an
hours-long blitz and bullet match and
after f5 once again le is up nearly a
minute on the clock
magician fee it looks great I like this
for black I would play king f7 you know
like haha that's how I play King your 7
h5 Bishop f6
just yeah
not even trap just so forget it yeah
Quincy 6ef fight for the win you are
good at blundering checkmate in one move
do not do this everybody watching I know
you look at super GM video Gujarati and
say if he's suggesting a move I should
listen he's just joking around because
that blood is checkmate when a Queen and
Bishop are lined up you don't want to
touch the pieces that are blunting that
diagonal and did it what is the point of
Queen c6 because like what has changed
besides the fact that one can't move I
wouldn't win ce6 anyways he if I was not
a big deal yeah looking at seven yeah
this king of stuck we keep talking about
it because the 97 is unchecked there's
can have seven yeah maybe quittance was
a good inclusion you just freeze white
for the time being and you know what I
do with white go Bishop D to move my
knight get Bishop c3 I need to exchange
that rookie - there we go
eight five eight four four black Oh at
94 94 yeah I don't love the knight being
over there but you have to right
yeah but d65 stuff you know kind of
extortions yeah
d6 on the move this pawn on c5 is you're
talking about week and rook e1 makes
perfect sense there sometimes you're
gonna take on a5 pressure down the
e-file yeah I will get just to be you
know safe safety first guys 61st you're
all about making sure that eight also
why don't you play b4 if we just go back
to that position like instead of before
I liked a5 and then play a four and then
before you know just like push all my
pawns open up the Queen side for my
pieces
okay maybe you know you know safe oh but
you should take safety very seriously I
advise everybody to be safe and I say do
as I say not as I do
I'm just trying to come up with
counterplay down the Queen side and then
I'm being criticized with my good friend
did a Gujarati so you're gonna date
sunny for mm-hmm I wouldn't do that
what's it it should take you by we
should be for checking each one okay she
does have his name Bishop c5 Bishop b4
he's a king each one well I don't like
what you did I don't like it I'd be
working but maybe just move Queen back
to c7 be force hanging
I'm shy I'm shy rooty - and in classic
they do is such a clever move I like it
you just attack the Queen yeah yeah
ditto makes perfect sense
I'm very surprised at what's going on
here don't
but the reason there is night of five
tactics you have to be alert and that if
I talk defies no I mean rookie - my
queen go anywhere there's nowhere to go
ah yeah this Ricky - move looks very
strong I would just walk windy - but
okay that's desperation but yeah no no
this is why is it not too late we
actually did it if I go roopd to night
at 5:45 night age for something like
this like two six fish it takes G - what
we should be six oh no he just didn't
sit up D - yeah now this'll do to your
plate right and now what is getting out
of it - nf2
what would you play Quincy six just get
it out from d5 I would think about
Quincy six definitely like 94 doesn't
work because rookie type in physics
makes sense
and now what's White's idea because II
six is defended the night array for
stuck the won't be sick doesn't
really have the best diagon to work with
so all the side would be like D to a 92
night of three
I like that diagonal for once and all
you close diagonal also threatened a
chief I'd check ideas I like it yeah c3
yeah edek and my way of thinking is
completely different what that's what
I've realized
matches your all strategic he's all
tactical and so there's no middle ground
and h5 okay uh what was nice going to H
for H three baby yeah h4 he plays
ninety-two it's for night of tea yeah
you're gonna just give me the g2 pond I
know what you're gonna do yeah well have
an H for at night of three Bishop f6 I
wouldn't be five fields wrong
it kills wrong she's going after the b3
pawn it feels greedy feels very greedy I
would still think about Knight f3 Knight
g5 stuff what else can you do your see
lighter feel Jake on beat three I was
trying to solve even all you intake on
f3 and takin beat you yeah it's because
my king is very safe on f7 yep even if
it has to go to GA even I have the h7
square to run to in the end of it all so
take an f3 when I gets there makes sense
see foreplay is Queen takes b6 a move
here what do you think about we take b6
cool cool move and then just bishop
before I guess it's 96 rookie 3 right
but Bishop d6 oh oh yeah it does work I
don't know it's pretty cool
yeah not my game not my piece is happy
to sacrifice them everybody knows this
but you look at the time look at the
time it would have made it easier so it
don't show me what to do don't tell me
what to do hey now can we take these six
you said look at the time and so I felt
like you were you know telling me what
to do and I felt like just have
necessity I have to protect my clothes
I'm just kidding so um May of 3 I don't
want to take that thing if you ship of
six yeah it up good move like Joe and
now I'm gonna take it
don't play it straight shilling it's the
Queen tacked on before the kind of that
yeah rook age five down the choices with
good analogy oh okay she's trying to
free her Queen this is also good wait
Bishop takes a four is it
Oh Queenie Savage oh so cool but this is
some kind of Queenie seven check stuff
like Bishop a4 Bishop a shade rock AJ
and the Queen 87 stuff final looks yeah
then you allow someone key six business
and yeah if you're looking to it b5
Bishop c3 Queen d7 queen bees black is
better
black is better for sure but he's been
tricky game after game Queen takes B
three ways no critics b3
can you steal that pond and winners you
should you should actually steal that
pond just otherwise you won't be uh she
practical yeah but too practical
probably not carve okay try of g2 or
what or work age five both those moves
look good
Bishop you to I like because I just
chopped over all the points yeah that's
smart move
I must get my 9025 be one play three we
should have resigned single exit is on
us and not 96 yeah I forgot to unites
thereafter I don't do sugar three take
the exchange
oc5 fish you have three back yeah now be
sure to go back please
rookies fraud actually looks good too
whoa this is not like no yeah this is
not yet so much time she has so much
time she could just think she is facing
five working seven so connecting GG six
is coming now yes I would say that she's
not coming in time pressure but she's
playing really bad in Eric's time
pressure weight is their major issue
look either make sense
snap same designs you've learned your
lesson already I thought Bishop e2 y y9
ta would be forward 98 there's no
relevance to the board
[Laughter]
Queen f praise be practical please do it
it's totally unnecessary like black is
winning in a million ways and rookie for
I guess is one of them group oh you
can't go Richie for I'm just blundering
it I'm so 85 how many ribs are under
attack two of them here P 3 is push the
pawns little bit before this is amazing
this room things b3 just out of
desperation steadily Ruchi fours me
finally finally and Wow
did you learn something from that I know
you have them saying to me IIIi didn't
learn something but I just having fun
that technique was the best I don't know
what to say
I really don't know what say that was
this this is Benedict
this has been a lot of fun but it's hard
to wrap your head around everything
that's happening so we now have the most
normal looking position we've seen today
right theoretical for Nightside Scots
through the queen is on e to rather than
f3 typically you should appoint on f3 in
this position and it's bishop now I want
to play f4 f5 or Bishop f5 or something
to take on e7 but doesn't look like it
gives me enough
now I just try to predict moves it's so
much more fun than analyzing I don't
think you're getting paid just predict
moves you know you said help me out be
that worldly gentleman that you are and
come up with nice strategies and crazy
tactics I came up with but nothing
happens like I played on the board this
is how most people play when they're in
tournament games okay so you don't have
that feeling when you're playing Bishop
f6 there was a very cool dr. Bishop g5
and I make my payment want it now you
did you did you absolutely did there any
check me on h7 the bish one d5 that was
a tactic that was available to white and
wasn't played because she's flanked so
quickly I still like her position from
the white side but she is playing
extremely quickly and sometimes missing
tactics that she would ordinarily fine
Bishop f6 was nice no just yeah well 95
in age five and it was very nice but it
didn't happen so now I need you to come
up with other strategies my other
strategy is Buki and then one more at a
time
you sound like Barea right it easy yeah
he was famously think I think he was the
one who said it that he only thinks like
two moves ahead uh okay and considering
he became number three in the world
worked out pretty well for him now
Bishop d5 Bishop DK water drop it would
be so Bishop g4 I was thinking at four
look they took it just to protect you
know I think a long term black is having
a better position yes I agree
in the like initial position it looks
very fragile because you're never sure
if you want to play a move like c4 for
black or play move like d4 because then
you give up the squares that's the
problem these hanging pawns if these are
called and c5 and d5 as soon as you push
one of them the square that it was
previously taking control of now is weak
and available to your opponent so that's
why Eric is keeping the pawns in their
place because it take away efore it
takes away c4 and d4 all these squares
are under blacks control Bishop e5 I was
advocating for this plan and all of a
sudden even if there's nothing serious
here knightly to the f4 type of idea but
that is like you cannot play rook e8 and
because of Bishop f6 and 95 again that's
a very nice tactic Wow
and if rook Bishop e5 I take any Rukia
Queen 65
yeah oh and there should and if I 25
made yep there's a checkmate on the back
rank here nice tactical vision by vivid
Gujarati I'm surprised that he's saying
good tactics he told me he was just
trying to try to guess the moves instead
he's coming up but then you put me in
guilt you put Ming guilt you have to
even like analyze now so put been killed
I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't mean to do
that to you so public
Bishop f5 now or you take on us I will
I would take because Bishop a5 as
whether you take on a5 and go D 44 right
but 94 yeah I'm jumps into this position
it's getting interesting 94 the funny
thing is your note read yeah it's your
route d5 even for black is available
there yeah so c4 I see all the chat
thank you everyone for the nice comments
and people love you for it
we all make mistakes but it's only
because of you that I can look at all
the puns because yeah I know I mean
otherwise nobody would hear it oh I'm
glad an audience you need an audience
I'm glad I opened the floor for you here
and I just saw amazing chess 210 in the
chest TV chances Wow
vid it is amazing go vid it all caps
thank you
it should be for hitting the work on a1
the bishop on e5 is still pin so you
can't even think about sacrificing the
exchange was taken up six unfortunately
one played wait wait a sec wait a sec
five or 97 97
f4 you have to play it cool oh you know
how that makes me go not good
I is there any mood for that you do
you're going 97 pain I would okay maybe
f4 okay now what well it's kind of
trapped on f5 so Bishop d6 like be 76 so
before Bishop e5 Bishop d4 that's how
I've been my get about what about rook
e6 here why a tricky guy you know what
you're like wait what are you doing man
and then you're like oh oh at Queen's
trap pretty quickly
I don't think it works so if rookie six
like rook f3 route g3 and things like
that we're actually white is turning the
tables on the attack
this is such a clever move I must give
it give that she goes Bishop d6 you know
Brooke before Bishop e5 Reuben Bishop de
food like we wouldn't sing like we are
thinking the same way yeah rook t4
Bishop e5 routine mission d4 check is
Peter but now looky one yeah you should
little q1 all you could play Knight b2
and be very sneaky
you are the sneakiest there should be
five Knight takes e4 hitting the Queen
in a hitting I love Knight B - I love my
pickle
I love Knight B to - we just had a
moment you heard that vid it okay well
that hurts
just for the record it doesn't but
Knight to be - looks really strong and
rerouting a pony into c4 and that's one
of the downsides of pushing your hanging
pawns when the pawn on d5 took away
squares like c24 as soon as you start
pushing them forward you give control
over some of these squares and now
Knight B - looks really strong and led
pay its has plenty of time he's up a
minute on the clock we see this game
after game and she what she's gonna
blunder she fall for she fell for the
trap he did what he trap into position
she did and she playing time to think
about it she walks like missing because
I thought like Eddie Pitts was black at
that time game and now you've realized
that you made a big mistake duty glasses
it was serious question I do have
glasses by the way but okay well I don't
see them on your face and yeah I don't
even well maybe you should because Ellie
pates has the white pieces you look at
your screen like you look at the bottom
of your screen at the moment that's okay
okay just making sure we're on the same
page here so I'm not gonna call this
game over because you've done that many
times and then things go wrong for the
side that's winning but he takes f6 is
for Sierra Queen trades happen the
Brooks come to the second ranking key to
room duel yeah I'm gonna go for lawn
mower on the
second rank is it good a lot more
doodles
uses the windmill but I feel like it's a
lawnmower situation here just you know
sorry not doing minute why not doing
window because I don't go with the
popular commentary did it I my own
person do mainstream do me exactly I'm a
contrarian by nature rookie to BAM
okie one I would play even okay you know
what you you got a one-up me and there
look what happened who played rookie -
that was international master Eric Rosen
did it's wrong wait it's wrong I will
feeling that this match is going to be
ridiculous well is that feeling because
it's two and a half two and a half right
now and so they're as close as it gets
because they're tied it's just you know
you did by the way means prediction so
it's just in my name do you get makes an
opera is that true because I have no way
of fact yes it's true but it means
knowing stuff let's see I'm googling
this right now it means to know so I do
know okay
I can't really find it right now
somebody else can verify but someone
find me the Snopes article on this you
really you will get your verification at
the end of the match I just well played
and air grows and just like that takes a
one-game lead three and a half two and a
half / le Payton I have to say I am
surprised Ellie has blundered away a
winning position she's made him allowed
to stalemate and that's going to be the
talk of the day I mean even if we know
that when the interviews come we are
gonna be talking about that still I'm
not gonna I'm not even ask that I for me
so I cannot ask it something like it's
like asking you about you not able to
win while being repelled you know
against me it's like asking you that you
know it's but you are asking me that so
you clearly don't care about my feelings
very one-sided friendship I
think I'm ending our friendship right
now so everybody watching it's over this
friendship is done I'm not commenting
with you anymore
and well you're on your own enjoy the
halls go Mike dog when you're gonna do
it you're gonna dope your headphones I
didn't see my um I have a mic and
everybody's asking me if they can be
friends with me
and the answer is probably not but maybe
it depends you gotta earn it you can
just ask for it anyway back to the chest
94 play are you gonna take with the F
pawn if I take you on e4 yes I would I
would take on the death bun and go eat
five next fare just trying to free up
some space for your pieces and e5
happening this pretty much no matter
what it seems like Elly really
understands these positions she gives up
the two bishops early but she gets very
quick play and you said yourself in it
that you played this type of style
through childhood and it just allows you
to play very quick moves with a clear
landing and it's frustrating for white
because you should be better with the
two bishops at least that's how you feel
but it's not always the case to make it
happen sure because like for two bishops
you need to have open portion and you
know it's it depends on a lot of factors
you just cannot take out two bishops and
claim advantage like if you get ninety
five here you would be better with white
so it depends on a lot of factors so
this which takes is f4 there it is as it
about to ask and she plays an f4 just to
keep the e5 pawn safer to make this
bishop look not so good on h2 but the
light square bishop now has more room to
work with
I was really prefer white oh I don't
know
no it's Knight c5 just give me give me
some improvement with my pieces Queen h4
will come at some moment hitting h3
hitting up to chef f5
okay bishop seed also make sense 94 or
visual visual
Bishop a5 Bishop a4 definitely would've
been the move and now I'm not sure she
would 85 seems a little slow and
unnecessary yeah she likes to push the
opponent as we have seen in the previous
match yes so every ever ef ef real
catchy
look g1 exactly right look in the center
yeah or start with regime 1 there it is
that way there's at least say at
attention but now you have a 94 kind of
fools to worry about right or not it's
true but 94 I just take Internet you're
taking a linear one and E 5 F for all
these are problems
I didn't like 85 it just felt a little
slow
so Queen takes three there's some Brooke
f3 stuff now rook takes f2 maybe not yet
but I'm eyeing that square Oh or yet so
now the positions opening up that a
queen takes e5 looks strong F oh if I
was very technically should be first not
bad either no no of course it's not bad
but I am over one in that prediction so
how do you continue this for white like
you're sort of looking like all your
pieces are pretty obvious where you have
no threats
exactly I have to be tricky so Bishop
before is no threat because taking on c5
and B takes e5 allows my Brooke to see
black also it's not so easy to come up
with Moses yes we're in this mutual
struggle of hey my position was
excellent but it's a steady mate yeah so
should I offer a drop or should I go buy
some McDonald's
I think McDonald's is now sponsoring
this that's clear I don't never say
never
we talked about this you told me you're
a believer now you're vague 56 what what
I just missed it rookie six I was doing
absolutely - Roxie - okay
the Queenie tree and then rookie seven
Oh am I missing something maybe of
Quincy six check in the end yeah
yeah I guess I do but still looks very
suspicious oh you can go chip at five
doesn't matter Queen D three threatening
a pretty important check on h7
intermediate moves like now you should
play Knight a failed program that's a
sad move to play yeah like we'd all take
on c2 no no I know
well Quincy - Justin you know that if
this were your game you would not be
sacrificing your exchange so don't do it
to other people
only I can do that stop stealing my
ideas sacrificing pieces is my stick
here
now you get all quiet on me and it makes
me feel self-conscious sorry I just like
to hear sometimes what the people are
saying and not to miss out them on any
questions or something or compliments
your your generous guy honestly we don't
deserve you 96 96 why you being so nice
today I'm not used to it wait 96 to the
rookie 7 now
yeah trying to sacrifice my rookie 7 but
doesn't work why white boy
yeah why you being so nice today I know
you upset about it 98 96 feels right
what else can black do because rookie
sevens are very deadly through it Brooke
f3 I guess it's possible that looks
terrible just take on 3
oh it was rook f3 and resins Queen f3
never say no trade on f3 yeah yeah yeah
it's just lost this is actually as bad
as it gets
yeah she means played like idiot she
should not have allowed so much play for
in the first case you know she had many
chances to play we should be for the
night before Bishop except three here
not over okay for one two should be four
give seven oh you're gonna take on g7 I
forgot about that movie you didn't ever
take g7 I'm still in the game but nope I
have seven yeah but then I have 96 DN
and I'm still I wouldn't be seven I'm
lucky seven just leave me alone I was
trying to make it okay seven look c7 did
it let fetch happen let it happen I love
it I love it when people say it's the
only move and then you suggest say four
moves and it kind of gets on the other
person's nose hello
this is over so she's thinking she's
spending her time this will be the
second elapsed game and this time
betrayed by the way I looked at the
clock so they will have time for one
more five-minute game and didn't let me
ask you something so as Eric goes on did
you take 75 minutes okay so it's like
one movement yeah one more game right
yeah but as Eric goes up to games my
question for you is does le haven't
abandoned a quicker time just because
she always is a huge lead on the clock
in these Bliss games yeah yeah I think
as I said it will be a close match don't
count it out it will be a close match
because she's not clean band but at some
points like you know one or two moose
are completely shocking right
she she she says has to be more
consistent with the Moose and then it
will be a very close match Eric he's not
making tactical oversights I think
that's been his biggest strength
I feel relatively at least not making
many oversights
I agree because unless of course you
blender some things but yeah he seems to
be quite sharp in some of these types of
battles but unfortunately for Ellie it
really has not seemed that she's been as
alert as possible and France and she
blundered that piece in the game was a
game well I I don't know what came at
this point but she blender the piece on
d2 at some point she the game she's up
in exchange a clear exchange and she
bitched about 5:00 and lost her bishop I
mean yeah up in Queen yeah if anyone is
spoiled opportunities it has been it's
Ellie yeah like if you just take that
statement game also and it's already
would be a different match we should be
it's research no resets I have to stop
saying resets this you could resign this
position because after taking a p6 wise
up how many counts for doesn't matter
wow you're a changed man this is just
you are showing the people that growth
is possible you know after that game
that was such a shock to me that was a
big shock to me that stalemate
yeah yeah that stalemate was thank you
have twenty seconds yeah a bit one like
five seconds I can understand that can
happen but I saw orient re let you check
meet him because he Prima on big G - so
so that oh yeah plenty of time on this
clock and these didn't happen deeply
moved did alright so we have a two-game
lead for Eric Rosen as we enter the
final game of the five plus one portion
we see that elevates takes a pretty calm
approach to this opening where she
didn't even play for the F four lines
like oftentimes when you play the early
bishops opening or play a sort of Vienna
structure that's not being this more
telling game in fact it says transition
right into it an Italian game but
sometimes you played for f4 if you
haven't committed your knight to f3 she
chooses this variation very safe and
sound
I think she wants to go and I do too and
g4 you know I feel because she's kind of
desperate to win a game that's just my
gut feeling
and Eric's smart to not castle yet
because you're saying g4 and g5 with the
hook on h6 that's a very forceful attack
by not castling and c4 cheerfully I
don't know what it means to know it you
didn't tell me that you haven't proven
it you've never hidden me any dictionary
where I could look that up and find out
if that is accurate so I believe you I
trust you as a friend but I still am
skeptical being skeptical is a good
thing so Knight g3 gone right into f5 I
like White's position always easier to
play me too and what would you play I
really not easy to come up with moves
right
maybe Queen d7 and Castle long but it
still looks Queen d7 95 when you go to
g8 yeah it's just gonna get very sort of
passive for a sec I would then maybe
should be three I think made upon just
to get this f4 square it's happening so
Queen d7 905 m g8
yeah Bishop e3
you know it's good I think any customer
faster at least in the initial phase he
has been a bit slow yes that's why I
asked you about the three-minute type
intro because while Eric has the lead in
this portion here he's always been down
a minute on the clock
pretty much every game we've seen thus
far he is the one down a substantial
amount of time so I think in the three
minute that should help her her chances
yeah yeah it's very important for her to
win this because then she's right back
in the match but if she loses this then
three-point deficit is kind of hard
psychologically
right Fe I'm predicting both of their
moves we're on fire you're doing very
Bellingham I'm very proud of myself
Queen takes 83 is a weird-looking move
it does stop black and cast and Queen
psychics and Queen h7 happens do chip
liquidity no I'm saying if you weren't
happy three I'm just saying you can also
take ok with the Queen but as vid it was
talking about now
this pawn on e3 takes care of the f4
square Eric drops his knight back to e7
but you still don't especially want to
take on a 5 thank you financially at GM
Black is fine it's not so bad
it's not that bad says vidit I like that
move Bishop CEO I was actually about to
recommend and the reason why is that you
don't allow Bluff to make too many
trades Eric wanted to take on b3 take on
a5 clarify the position but now no
matter how you take on f5 we some more
minor pieces and white has more space to
work with right and I'm D focus on lying
wolf you know for sure putting pressure
on e5 yep Bishop C - I like it
and Eric once again going to the think
tank down minute on the clock you want
to play d5 is black but you hang the e5
pawn can't get away with that I'm Queen
b5 is really just a one move threat on
b2 and it's like threading it it's not
doing 3rd yeah yeah I think GF GF is the
move and then g6 I'm taking ef ef then
if I like EF well it's cuz you didn't
suggest it but now that you're looking
at you're like oh actually I kind of
like the number 96
because GF before you know I have this
like super nice Center
yeah I'm old school I like solid center
and stuff like that
what's wrong with whites maybe e4 is
queenside their daily for d5e 492 d5
yeah we fine
I can go Knight B 3 to c5 and just
bother you and the Queen side maybe I
don't know
yeah a little more sleeves yeah the kid
allows d5 and now you for next oh I
don't like it I don't like it either
look how much space White has oh yeah
this is not place always like a big time
difference like a minute and a half
right as usual and
so look these nights on a 7 and h7 so
you try to stop g5 over here on the
kingside h4 g5 still possible of course
anymore Bishop d3 is trying to cut this
night away from b5 where's my dad not
really necessary people is saying that
we are not reading the chat but I am
keeping a watch on it so I'm also
keeping a watch and is good
I see great shot in the chat shadow he
won the Manship yesterday right yes he
did and also there's a comment I see on
YouTube saying hey vid it eagerly
waiting for the April 25th charity games
so people are looking forward to your
charity chess
I'm 25th with Vichy with Tanja I forget
about Nihal you know and like and they
will be able to tell puns that will
actually be good too thank you for
organizing his event everybody knows I
can hear the good puns from actual
comedians oh not from my friend did it
who struggle sometimes with hey you know
question for you I don't think I
struggle with my jokes just to put it
out there but you know it's like is this
a beauty lies in the eyes of the
beholder and I think it's the same when
it comes to job you have to have the
taste to appreciate this anyways back to
the game by this better what do you
think about white spatial advantage here
I love it I like space advantage and
wait is that Queen almost trap now in PC
six quickly since I think what quite
chilly I think we have to get this edge
football under would you believe okay
j-tier yes the side move but would you
do it
yes I would because I like sad moves and
the reason why is G six runs the problem
opening the F file and the Queen lands
on f7 so something like this okay with
the clear on a fade I devote his gamut
by accident between Bishop d3 now but
then Queen a food right
cook she won what is why trying to help
us here
yeah I want to exchange one night with
black and I would just denied c5 at the
first chance
well you just had a chance and he played
Queen to b6 and also please c6 later on
you know open up c4 Oh
seafood looks weird 192 yeah you said
there should be email for when I say uh
you just said okay and I think we still
emo for you Queen Asia we bring before
we need before all suppose we need me
but it would go c6 here it's like a
tickling move you know we kind of just a
chance at effects yeah he wants to play
b5 line
I've understood Eric's game he was be
fight okay ladies I didn't either
ip3
at I think we need 525 is not even a
thread because 93 92 checked but 965 is
right yeah but good good i i'm like king
a queen a 593 queen a 692 check and then
you pick up the queen next and black
goes up a piece a good time he sees a
concession or okay Oh Timmy's if I'm
very close
beat you a for Bishop a4 median then
then what King a meet but your knight is
stuck on a 7 which is what I could play
c6 I could play c6 King c7 c6 is risky
but I I agree with you that yeah you
have to be believable you have to
believe we talked about this you
believer you so what is White's plan
here a3 King it to feel slow okay at
some point of any Bishop d7 Queen 84 but
it doesn't work Braves to a3 first can
you do me one exactly Freddy's little
what what I like to do in such portions
is like just stop all my opponents ideas
and that's more frustrating than coming
up with something and then flag them
they should be 5 in a second be fine no
I will not play we should be 5 I would
see one protect seafood Queen each and
then cook we need to yeah yeah that's my
plan because you want to open up the
second flank right now on the Queen side
black is totally locked up over here and
so is white but the h5 pawn that is the
weakness in the positioned rook h3 plate
okay I you know the brook could come
over to say c3 now we need 250
play Queenie to go after this pawn yep
White has a fantastic but oh no white
will be three and c6
ok b6 f6 f6 disrupt b6 and absolutes
absolutely good spot if 16 is night and
take I didn't see that I didn't see it
good and she had there it is okay she
found it the time difference again like
huge yeah like one and a half minutes
against 20 seconds and it's been the
same throughout the match brick f1 rook
T okay brick f1 was just decisive one
given there was 94 by the rook F 1 Oh
Queen C 3 certain ad no capsule is
certain by the way yep
that's a really nice circle can be 6
good move Queen g5
25 take on each five go after up seven
there it is no place it's really hard to
play this portion you know what I liked
about Ellie in this game is that she
really stopped all the counter play she
didn't give no chance no chance to open
up that's what it was good and sometimes
when you lose a couple of games that you
should win you get extra cautious now I
would take taken group win g5 just to
kill all the counter play that's really
nice you saying take and play Queen g5
because once the Queen's on e7 you have
to trade Queens otherwise you lose your
night on e3 yeah I think even in
girlfriends book you know he says that
one of the best ways to convert is to
kill all your opponent's counterplay yep
and there it is yeah when she fell and I
was going to say that Ellie is extra
cautious in this game and she puts
slowly not going to the Kings side
because she have lost game to some
tactical battles and now she very wisely
just says okay I've got everything under
control
trading Queens the Jeep on starts
pushing the knight housing sacks yep
jeez I'm begging ya just don't bring it
to eat too right because on this night
up for check on so I would play I would
a Jackie one king of - oh but actually
that black king is coming very quickly
over there yeah but this King City is
nice big flat one and it should be lost
yep yeah that was a partner very smart
and the leg that she's thinking of
taking a pause before playing she has 30
seconds why not because again I was you
know kids black went d5 at some point as
a pre move and she doesn't move King
takes a five and all the team on the run
exactly
she's learned her lesson you could say
yep blue Bishop c6
wait okay eat food no no no just take up
c5 and then get a queen take on c5 Oh
what this work yeah
what no it does not oh my gosh no this
has been food No
and she moves creeping Japanese oh my
gosh she's gonna lose this game Queen
cheering general I can't believe this
for them oh this is so painful this is
so painful
oh my gosh bid it again
missus
oh my god I just it's just so upsetting
what if she doesn't lose this game
though
I just keep the Queen and then bring
your king in come on
oh my gosh well on that note it's a sad
one we will be going to our first break
Eric Rosen has a three point lead over
le pates in what has been an absolutely
shocking match thus far when we come
back we will get ready for the
three-minute portion where le page will
hope her time advantage plays her added
to her edge but so far unfortunate for
her she has not been able to convert
winning positions we will be back stay
tuned everybody
[Music]
and we are back getting ready for the
three-minute segment of the I am NOT GM
speech s championship and just to remind
everybody that I am the main commentator
here but I also am playing a match
alongside my good pal Danny wrench he is
important match tomorrow in this very
event but after that on Saturday April
25th he and I take on the Spanish
commentators so hopefully Team USA can
win that matchup and Danny will hope
that he can get in a good state of mind
before he takes him Wesley so in the
adopt Danny special when he takes on one
of the best players in the world
Grandmaster Wesley self in the USA and
finally Danny will have to let his words
do the talking rather than his
questionable play when he does the state
of chess calm so everybody should tune
in just to hear what's going on behind
the scenes of chess calm what's going on
with the company and all the good
initiatives in store now that we've
gotten all that taken care of enough for
the PSAs vidit we're heading into the
three-minute portion what are your
thoughts last game was completely crazy
I mean what a turnaround what a
turnaround like it was so painting you
don't even need to explain it the so
winning and - I'm just shocked because
it happened twice here like it just when
you think it's over
and then it's not I was gonna say even
in the endgame
she went to move King d8 into the King
CA when she's trying to promote the pawn
I move 77 Chevy adoption and it just
feels like literally nothing is going
her way in these positions and under the
duress of time trouble and just the
nerves are getting to her but it's only
a three point lead for era Rosen it
seems like Elly is the faster player of
the two so I in the three minute portion
less time to think for Eric it feels
like I should play to her advantage yeah
yeah she's playing faster but the one
thing is like when Eric is in time
pressure she should really take her time
she should really take the time and
finish him off when she gets the chance
don't you let him off the hook and you
recognize this opening did it yeah we
played like thousand games here ecigs
you play this like hippo setup it's very
slow in casual AC hey did it this has to
look familiar but she played a little
bit more actively with Knight to c6 the
good thing is that Eric saw our stream
so he has some point does how to play it
white yes some bad pointers and how to
be like video Gujarati and not take full
advantage of a questionable opening and
the reason is opening is questionable
from the black sides we look at white
center with the pawns and c3 d4 and e4
very well protected
you know nicely centralized 'if I've can
be played at some moment so we can fish
one g7 look like it's not doing much of
anything
and now b2 to b4 is also an option for
Eric because inputs this time you take
this opening seriously like you know you
give away so much of space advantage and
you don't deserve to you know kind of
like even fight that's what I feel like
whenever I see this opening I feel like
I should crush my opera but it's not
easy because it feels like that and then
you extend yes and here's an example
with Bishop h4 stabbed by a Knight to f5
and you already removed one of White's
bishops bishop back to d2 next to d5
then you play or try to play from like
c4 you like B 3 C 4 but as you've said
you start overextending and once those
pawns go forward they're not coming back
you know I have a feeling that she's on
a tilt because she's playing really fast
and like like the moves would she play
like d5 and stuff you know it shows that
she's kind of on the small tilt though
she certainly is and she should be after
what has happened in the 5 minute
because based on play I don't think she
should be down three points but mm-hmm
based on how she's played when she's
completely winning she should maybe be
down three points so that's a weird
thing to state the way I had one choice
okay
so just Ricky ate here just just defend
the bond there we go good move don't
trade anything just yet
she's probably considering if she can
know people are going crazy because at
some point she sneezed and they're like
he was a sign at hazard for chance I
[Laughter]
missed her sneezing I mean you're
focusing on the chest did it and not her
sneezes bless you bless you my friend
edge Ford you want to go forward
aggressive attacking stuff with this
Queen d2 Bishop f3 oh gosh wait what we
should did you take step three
completely ruined white pawns yeah yeah
she she probably the moolah now wait for
what is going to do pledge for h5 yeah
and even that you know h4 h5 adventure
goat g5 of course it's a good idea to
just start attacking this pink and red
structure 94 kind of shows lack of plan
yeah I would even play at 6 f5 you know
I like it just taking away the g5 Square
from the night before playing f5 and d5
was a consideration at some moment but
you have of course it to get your queen
off the e-file before you play like that
f5 play Knight to g5 what's her idea oh
no this is ugly this is ugly
Oh give me the e5 square for this Pony
to just hop right in okay knight c6 the
deep one is pinned and I mean to just d5
is it it's it's like a hanging sword you
know right dangerous but dangerous for
both because when you play them like d5
and you get nice laid upon you can come
to regret it
right now h6 the opportune like you have
to consider the 5 at every movie and
every what I meant by hangings for yes
and you still are considering d5 that's
why I wanted a pledge for not allowed g5
why would I allow this expansion pledge
foot completely stop it because if you
get g4 in that Knight is kicked and then
t4 is a victim of the position
look at that Bishamon b1 vidit it's not
really doing all that much here so d5
finally I see that Robson V has joined
us shout out to him
GM ray raphson rooting for his former
college teammate Eric Rosen they both
attended Webster University uh-huh which
is led by Susan Powter look at this g4
move saying please take my men and c6
I'm taking right on their 3 opening up
the kingside and what you also get the G
files so yes it's a fight for the G file
who gets it first white you think so I'm
gonna agree to disagree with you my fear
not completely view but Edie no does it
look
wait what Yugi said oh because the
background check means but you have a
mean for yeah yeah but you de D Bishop
g7 you have to take me on e - yeah
then I take back with my rook f5 is no
Queen g7 yeah your right is background
checkmate so if I take on a5 you take on
c4 and okay this also makes sense take
on 16 Joey D but now you have C D which
doesn't happen obviously and C these are
a thing of the past minute notching of
84 catching up I would have played
Knight a5 in Knight d4 or school you
should have played 94 94 was nice Queen
e2 is also pretty pretty cool is
bringing the Queen to try to check me on
the background CDs are the thing of the
bust
I like your comment thank you appreciate
them so night 65 Queen had two queens
they touch to the e1 square so yeah yeah
and I'm starting like White's position a
lot
Queenie five hello Oh what was that
being off the Queen e5 that was the
nicest way you could have said it hello
I felt like you were you're talking
right to me Queen Daisy no problem
so Queenie 365 in the 97
Knight of five Queen at 6:27 yep
checkmate
everything that could go wrong is going
wrong going wrong yeah it's it's tilt
it's just it just nothing can go right
for at this point and I just do it in
the chat that the bun bar is low it is
low because I've been commentating with
you and Dania and you guys just keep
hitting me with these I don't even know
how to describe them four-point lead
four-point lead
so this should be a more comfortable
position for her she's by 92f way I like
black you sir doing such portions i like
this double bonds b 5 before stuff so
yeah you have to play a 3 B 5 loop C 1
you should not have a beef yeah take 95
o de yeah why don't you take 95 for its
cuz you said rook c1 so she played rock
c1 and now how I thought it was obvious
that you should know she's playing so
fast it's she's angry yeah he's very
angry yeah this is okay you do get
compensation taken I thought yeah they
gonna fire an f3 is exactly but now
she's in that mode where you you're like
I don't care it's enough more you know I
just play and then you start winning
games and then you feel super excited no
it could happen
GF now is just wrong GF + f3 because h6
softens the g6 square for a future work
that you want to take on a GF is always
right if you know what I mean nice and
she does it f3 okay I guess you could
play f3 for it you know the next bunch
of moves but yeah she should have good
at f3 the king that is better than f2
then e2 anyway
okay take I can't play f3 you think it's
gonna happen
nope FC should have been played ages ago
yeah did I quit nothing I say happens it
feels like I'm not being listened to
you recommend I do we should be fooled
sorry I was just I mean look at the
turn-on like black is not winning just
night before Andrew K 2 and to bishops
pawn up yeah it's pretty upsetting to
see this honestly
I mean what rook' to take on D to f4
this is looking bad from worst to worst
is really how I'm seeing this game yep
yep it's yeah she needs a victory and
this kind of win at all costs mentality
is costing her because you know it's
such yep sorry you sorry to put you off
but I realize that in such situations
the best way to do is like be extremely
resilient and not to lose a game you
have to first stop the bleeding right
and you have to be extremely resilient
like you have to play try your best
chances you don't be very tricky and
then once you get the rhythm back then
you play going on tilt hardly ever helps
you lose more than you win and that's
been very clear in this matchup where
she's trying to force a win from thin
air and Erik is playing way too well and
resourceful aid for her to just win
because she wants to win and here comes
e3 and she resigned oh well I think she
is frustrated naturally we can sense
that and etic is just sipping his tea
and collecting the points yes and
exchanged French interesting decisions
c4 is he gonna play that line or is he
yep there it is it's the more aggressive
version of the exchange French and so
the bishop on c4 I is this f7 pot black
needs the castle quite quickly is 95 I
move here wait what
what's wrong with 95 wait there was
resigns 95 was it is that 95 95 Queen h5
threatening f7 through h7 would check me
yep yep
yeah there's nothing more to explain
and that's an example where you assume
your opponent went in blunder on move
seven or whatever them yeah move seven
so you just play quick move his white
but that was just crushing and okay
Black's not doing so badly here it's not
particularly lovely but it's not so bad
he five she's continuing to do this yeah
I would go d6 and Bishop b3 and 94 and
just to enjoy the position okay a many
moves good yeah
Bishop takes g6 and B take seated on
don't take on g6 right now why not even
that is good
BC Bishop c2 you're trying to go for a
checkmate just line up the Queen yeah
but he's thinking and she's up almost a
minute on the clock and this is why I
thought she would have good chances in
the three-minute but she can't she can't
stop the bleeding just yet and Bishop a
c6 is played take on c3 so I'll play
Bishop c2 presumably
I actually don't mind blacks position
here though I understand what you're
saying that there's a potential for a
king Senate AG d6 that's a pawn that
might just be gobbled up we should see
to the bishop seat you are always at
Bishop a6 lucky one but then you're not
getting Queen d3 you know so like at
least I'd be 1 and the rookie 7 like you
know there are no pieces near the blacks
King that's true here you're not wrong
with that statement may rookie 86 right
now and do it quickly even that I think
why this fantastic compensation yeah
it'll be too soon
yeah but looky-looky 6 was the best try
I do admit like take the d6 pawn yeah at
least remove that thorn from the
position why did she fly Queen d8 when
she just brought a queen back to a5
there was no purpose of putting on d8
first you know
and what can Eric do here but this is a
safe position that's very frustrating
from white because you know you're much
much better here but winning it is not
that clear at the moment and then you
think is queen c3 a threat is you know
rook da takes d6 going to happen
obviously white is doing extremely well
here but you're down down a minute and
20 seconds on the clock it's like a
really stressful situation
okay so night at 5:00 is also worrying
me for in addition opening d3o Quincy
yeah but Queen III is nice
hey Queen it is nice take that pawn for
the Queen d3 would you click with the
tree or Quincy - mine would be exchange
Queens probably my first instinct would
be to play Queen c2 but then I don't g6
is happening and how am i protecting is
d6 pawn but Knight a5 yeah I was about
to say that
yeah not if I was cool just i living up
giving up the night to go for a
checkmate this king of yeah week I love
it
no fun but wait look it's two-minute
time advantage fit in this is getting
tricky because g6 95 King h7 right like
you're getting an attack but you're
moving very slowly Queen d2 doesn't
threaten anything the Brooklyn Beach is
under attack
so black just needs but you can take
bishop g6 in the India like Queen at
6:22 okay King itself is quite enough
this night White Knight a so at the
Queens under attack how's the blunder my
queen I don't know but CB CB o Queen d5
and just couldn't beat you or something
yeah and then put Queen on default yep I
like that there is take on there it is
all happening Queen d4 oh no like she
had a minute and fifty something sec
yeah yeah it's just you have to play
good chess problems bishop g6 95 Queen
d7 Bishop g6 but everything's in time
trouble finding that move I would just
like Queen takes a two here and hope
that I can somehow survive but yeah it's
not it's not ignite but nygean I G oh
you had missed night you nice you take
this thing
Queen d5 play 25 there it is
she's actually probably not even losing
right now rook e8 why she's not losing
she's like down one pawn and I've
fainted seven Queen h5 and then I g14 f3
ah you get it after but still absolutely
very nervous yeah whoa whoa what wait
wait
Bishop e2 quit 61 at the very least
critics deewana and IDS's but only black
can be better but wait do you know you
even have Queen okay it doesn't matter
okay I mean this is the position that
you couldn't ask for something better
from her perspective is organizing our
94 at 4:00 you lose the piece so don't
do that that does a good 50 just to show
that the King goes here you you Oh
actually don't lose keep king of five so
you actually don't lose the piece
but she just was a king closer to the
Queen side and now the black pawns
because white on two seconds two seconds
nicely for the great move so long time
yep she got it King b5 this is the
tournament she needed
yeah just bliss low just couldn't work
this you cannot bluntly mess up right
right oh she's mess up many jinx it
don't jinx it
I'm sorry vidit I'm sorry but you can't
possibly not win this game King do the
reason don't see - it's not still mini
king B to get a queen it's okay Lord
isn't fine so she was like you know I
cannot do this
she must be relieved because she played
a bad game and she won and honestly
that's how she must be feeling but like
I've been out playing this guy and I
can't buy a point now that I played a
questionable game I want and now she's
going to the nimza Larson attack which
is 1 B 3 F 4 it's all very suspicious
stuff because the bishop on d6 gift 3
like g4 I will go Knight G Ford and put
black Bishop g4 also makes sense yep 94
there was 93 so she takes an f6 work up
- I've had this position many times in
online blitz exactly all the time yes he
does and it's very difficult for black
because Queen f1 here and now that white
is fully coordinated look at your pawns
should be 5 I'm I'm a believer little do
bishops I am too usually but I'm just
talking from practical experience it's
not easy to play even if black is
ultimately okay just like the ideas in
the position make it somewhat hard
bishop mean vibe though now Bishop e5
threatens rook takes d2 and Bishop takes
c3 what
doo-doo-doo-doo was then no I saw that
but after each takes I wasn't quite
convinced that this is worth it
like d3 here rookie ones even probably
better
and see - maybe is in trouble
Quincy for well you see when he said
yeah she once said yeah she I she she
went rookie one and then put her back
and then just blunders on this you know
I just want to go there click the mouse
play to three games bring back the
scoreboard and then give it to her and
then say please it's like now Ricky one
now I would not know that played Queen
III but you know take on f2 take
everything play Bishop see - just take
all the bonds but then rookie seven-year
wears chances to hold that position of
course black is up a couple pawns in way
better but you do feel like the worst is
sort of behind you
it's roofing sheets you apostle in here
no right kings you do know and then what
I want to go Bishop h3 check but yeah my
queen d4 just take enough to play Bishop
c2 two pawns off so do you think she
could survive this no boy the tide is
really not in available wait just rook T
to Queen f2 here
yeah our queen yeah I mean see that's
why you know when you get the point you
should just take it and did it watch out
if you try to make a move like Queen d7
or something Queen a7 so Queen f2 is one
of those moves that you're trying to
trade Queen to get the endgame but if
you're not careful as black Queen a7
comes and here you can't do the rook and
you once I mean but cuase ever comes
then you like oh the tables have turned
very quickly see for reasonable very
reasonable
I would blip b6 you know just stop that
night on a food that's sadist but it
just mean me against that so what is
blacks plan to to press for a win at
this point I don't think this is it you
know okay should I shut it shall I say a
pun I'm scared but sure chess player
went to the church and his sins were
forgiven why
because he had two bishops advantage
that that ones breath
that one is beyond that I need help and
he is not from the two bishops that you
just said in that pot that was so bad
you are something else
anyway a minute on the clock and it
feels like Eric is he's not playing the
optimal chess here he had a great
position
early on he still has these double pawns
on the ephod double callings in the C
file so creating a passed pawn will not
be easy and Bishop e1 is always gonna
find Knight c3 g6 f5 yep yeah bishop
straps the bishop C to Bishop c2 now
does King D - you should be four yeah
yeah what about C takes b5 here CBA be
no then Bishop c6 no Knight c3 now I
should take on c4 probably wait what
should I do
qingxue that was my that was my idea but
this is you should be three king do -
bishop BG right now that's my idea in
the earlier position and said this is
where we are 94 played because if you
take who is even better in the same game
black can't be better King takes King
you six look at the time difference it
since in two minutes against like 16
seconds
do you play f5 check and just you know
close everything down for white or is
there somehow it wait what now black
clicking play at five
I guess the 5g 5 FC no but an h4
actually white can win that with an
outside pass pawn if you're not careful
you'd have to help me out a lot I think
it's a draw
but it should be so now what do you do I
mean now this is actually getting tough
for white key no but g5 is still at all
right take you should have played g5 a
few and here comes h5 now agh 5 let's
have you an image photo and then okay
King edge food yep and then it's getting
close but yeah I guess because even just
start losing Tempe for black with c6 or
a 5 but the white king
hg king people and then King f6
oh yeah King of 6 that's just simply
been like oh my gosh and it's like black
has yeah King of 6 is easy just to
claims yeah you shouldn't lose this
position this is just she fought so
valiantly and then were here um why is
he wasting all this tempos why Keeney
for nothing wait was king of three I
guess doesn't matter
it's a draw now such a simple win you
know you waste all your extra degrees c
6a v kz why would you do that
yeah I am I'm struggling today I'm gonna
be honest with you this has been a tough
match to predict because one side is
logged with it well the side that is
winning doesn't win that's really what's
happened to her
yeah yeah true and this is like the
fifth time we see this was opening has
there been a game where the end result
matches the play no I mean there have
been but it hard to remember at this
point yeah yeah Wow
yeah I I don't have the words for this
so Bishop c4 Knight g5 you can just play
d5 I guess okay I 95 you would you would
play or what no no five ugly
yeah but 95 is also August 1985 here
actually Queen wait what up Queen b3
here when you've met night maybe 696
first nineteen 626 Queen b3 finally nice
nice nice nice that's a good one so he's
thinking he's gonna find it it's not
gonna be fun for there it is
play 92 for here out of just sad
necessity no please don't
yeah why not eighty stage for you okay
it'll be nine four I think because this
portion is like positionally also you're
bad and you just know yeah we see a
point about force yep yep habit nope I
got nothing for you here but it i I've
got nothing no ideas whatsoever
she would play tonight takes at 4:00 and
give up a queen and hope that somehow
she can survive
you're so quiet you know I just I don't
know what's going on did it oh yeah I
was I was thinking of a pun but I am
resisting and I'm controlling myself
let's not get carried away
95 and why not 95 she's really a nice
heat shrink when sorry and then just
gonna win the end game very easily
Bishop takes d6 thank you for a second
bomb
if you don't like Bishop d6 play king d2
Brooksie one and just win the endgame
elicits all this tick three pumps always
take them rook e8 go for tricks
wait what we should have faced yes that
that hangs this rook here why you see
not picking you know it's again it was
just deciding if he should take on e6 or
allow Queen digsy final trade then he
just fell asleep off T before taking it
yeah he looks pretty calm over there I
mean I wish I had better commentary for
what's happening in this match but it's
just total tilt yep told tilt and after
le won that game she had no business
winning earlier then it feels like two
game without any game like she ended up
winning the night versus Bishop endgame
where she was able to promote you don't
remember it no there was a pawn on d6
for white White's act the Queen to go
yeah yeah oh yeah now that you remember
and know what I'm talking about it feels
like after that game she needs just to
calm down and play her normal chess
because when she's playing her normal
chess she can take on Eric Rosen but she
keeps doing this like offbeat openings
and questionable lines and you know and
then Eric's finds a tactic called
sequence that crushes her yep gimme five
okay I mean it's hard to even government
it when it's like plus ten you would win
king of the hill with king e5 watch out
for nineteen be two that's the one thing
you had to be careful about cuz if I get
night eggs b2 and rook takes c3 did I
have very legitimate you know I would
play Knight d5 Kinsey 597 so greedy I
just take three points no nope
yeah I mean it's good that's good for
you I have nothing to say I like that
he's just thinking wasting more time off
the three-minute section right because
with a big match leader for games as far
it'll sit next to
me too no oh my gosh and I think you
check it exactly I was saying the rook
can take take rook c3 and then black
actually has tremendous counter play
here I love your expression of now you
do it's just these players are so much
better than allowing these tactics and
something is not right oh yeah I'm
exasperated here
so yeah I mean it's it's I mean I don't
even want to suggest moves because
what's the the night to so naughty to
play that's angry just yeah just night
before before before at that little
before trap in the reverb c7 first
Brooke F 1 check picks up the Bishop on
g7 but it would take beat you at the end
Libby yeah good movie she should
resign and just eight more times play a
board okay nice III also works but the
rook is trapped and b5 it was even more
sad to play okay seven you know and not
even give the but did it I mean nineteen
speech you check is something that Ellie
has to see right yeah no I think it's no
now she doesn't believe that she can
come back like you can sense it that
fighting spirit kind of his she's just
playing out of inertia she needs like
one or two wins at least we believe that
can happen that's where I was thinking I
think if she can win two games in a row
then she starts believing in herself but
until that happens she's just like this
matches out of control I'm down five
points now and she's probably
disappointed with her play that's all
chess players are like yeah I mean we
might get imagine agony mentioned yeah
you win a game and you're like oh it's
like terribly I should have done this
this and this oh wait but you just won
one of the biggest games your life and
you're like yeah but I played awfully i
blundered upon and I gave a square that
I shouldn't have given up this is the
nature of chess players and for Ellie
here I think she's doing a good job in
this particular game we keep saying that
but yeah I think one of the things what
you should do is like as a chess player
I've noticed that you should never use
the word blunder because it has such a
strong impact psychologically oh I
blunder then you know it completely
shakes your confidence yeah what I've
learned is just to say okay I made a
mistake it doesn't have that big an
impact so it doesn't affect your next
game so whenever now I make a bad move I
just say it's big mistake or a big
mistake just mistake you know there's
nothing like blunder it's easy for you
to say when you know you so rarely make
mistakes because you're a super GM I'm
just kidding of course but I think it's
a very good thing to keep in mind that
when you make a mistake it's not an
indictment on your personality or like
on you or something because blow using
how how can I make that right mistakes
happen but in some ways it's better to
like blunder your Queen um of eight than
it is to lose a game where you're
winning and then everything just goes
wrong and you lose a game that you're up
a bishop in like the end game because if
your blender movie yeah that won't
happen to me again but when you slowly
lose the thread you start crushing all
of the quality of your moves
mm-hmm is it be folk doesn't work yeah
there is a bien Bishop of to check right
so should be fine I don't like a five I
would like to keep this you know this be
five thread because there's better to
keep that I would have won castles maybe
I think hassle there's some Knight h5
stuff that she's big as thinking it's
two or something yeah I like that idea
for sure and Bishop III yeah this is too
soft with a 5-1 Bishop III not in this
police it no Bishop c4 and 97 you don't
lose upon now you know the pawn but this
feels like it he's good change for black
it feels like a good exchange for black
just how good knight c6 and Bishop a4 is
no fun
SC six so I want to put my bishop on b3
go after f7 but you can go Knight b5 and
I'm not really getting anything
it should be three played good moves up
now Knight g5 you should avoid but okay
96 here yeah so I would go okay 96 94 is
the threat so kind of annoying actually
how do you even defend that on there are
Islam this is very hard to stop nice six
and you win this pawn so how do you have
it mmm you can't probably don't you know
know you can go to k1 or 96 quindi 390
EGA win sequence it sir exactly yep and
if icon is falling what's the numbers
agreed no but not Quincy five that
doesn't look right
Team B six yet this is where i'm what i
meant by resistance you know you have to
keep finding small tricks you have to
not give it easy but she may be five
ninety do she's way more time though so
oh but ninety five is a good move should
be five CD and then see for just play
that just do it and do it quickly it
should be five CD v c four undermine the
defense in this knight on e4 and just
play you have to i'm not saying it's
good I know black is better but you're
part of fifty-five seconds
what
actually it's kind of interesting Rick
what happened I missed the last moose
she went rob thicke nanny for giving up
her queen and boy okay it's two pieces
for the Queen that's like not supposed
to work
oh please like okay I gotta show this
analysis for time instead of Queen e5
you put f6 not only is night f7 check
deposit 96 is me
it's g6 bed tonight was checkmate how
does it show that when it's available
because incas adds options at this place
so instead we see the trades and what
this Bishop needs to do is reach the c8
Square somehow is releasing like o66
doesn't work when I would find you have
to no jumps I debunked g6 King just 7g
saved me Bishop c4 you have to keep an
eye out and Bishop takes 86 sacrifices
yep I agree
Oh Pookie - wait wait is there a
sacrifice there well no it doesn't work
out it doesn't work out so did this some
deity as always we'll come back to be a
little kid Oh probably Oh blunder you
fight good move
yep Roxy to Bishop g4 play Bishop g4
because Bishop c4 is nice rook takes a 6
is the threat oh that's such a nice you
take three I just take and if you take
the other way I take yeah James you
thought I would go to b8 I'm just trying
to show everybody the tactic that I'm
looking for
let's see there it is he's 20 seconds
he's I think is gonna miss it I really
do okay six
I called that everything nice and you
were talk about resilience
she actually put a great resilience in
this game yep yep in the end game she
did put the great president I agree
and here comes that be parts of rook a 7
just go gobble be seven or maybe you do
to her okay chick yeah you get to check
on b7 now I wouldn't have given the
check maybe
me neither but she did it and I'm just
gonna prove rook takes h7 look at seven
yeah take all the ponds there is b7 b
seven rubadoux Maybrook c7 and give up
c4 okay now King no g3 just what to do
tough tough to play a move which oh I
like that G 45s me she loses a she's
bonding with the upon the really key 3 C
to me you don't get fully ones and look
back just give me the SI phan take on c3
yep she throws in the check first and
then take on c3 or the tube going to
check I don't know but as long as you
take some the c3 their King g3 that's
fine too
how is she gonna wing it three looking
at three and how a point in g3 maybe I
don't know what's up do you Oh what was
rook g3 okay
King edge three she's just not pranking
it there it is finally g3 it'll be do
people anyway yeah Oh f4 that was a
strange decision but Kenner king somehow
make it no no it's just a daughter b7
bro oh nice rugby sevens a nice find
check and rupee seven now why to be late
he's fine for when you can't win in this
position it's easy to forget about rook
takes p7 because you know okay it could
be a little b7 or he'll take it now yeah
that said Wow um Eric I was called the
Eric vid it a vid it
I don't know what to make of that game
my head is spinning I know it's a
I agree with you it's
the veins it's no nobody's winning the
one positions so far yeah that's really
been the theme and how many point five
points still in the lead for Eric so
this is not going well for Elly she
needed to win that game somehow even
though she was losing I start with yeah
white blue very mysteriously in this
game like so many times P down yeah it's
like a very comfortable position take
only for booboo sheriff I go c5 your
attack your best defense rookie to c5
okay Quincy 793 390 D 393 Bishop g5 and
then nighttime then g4 yeah I wanted to
go a night a force amount but your yeah
yeah
okay but somehow the first time I see
edek bling fast so fast
yes after long time and and somehow wise
position actually turned out pretty good
but how many how much time do they have
like how many more games do you think
they can play they have about five
minutes hello or five minutes oh if this
game ends relatively shortly then
they'll have at least one more after
this I just wanna shout out to everybody
who's watching I know yes 7000 thank you
across all the platforms we have a well
over 8000 as I look across or so thank
you so much for tuning in we really
appreciate your support
Lydia and I are trying to give you well
as much enlightenment as we possibly can
it has been a whirlwind in this matchup
both players have been playing some
great games that have been totally
ruined by tragic blunders but right now
it does feel like Eric Rosen in the
critical moments he's finding the right
path forward and holding on to top
positions even winning some completely
lost positions and for Elliot it's
unfortunately for her she has struggled
to die we should defy probably OSI 45
isn't it very dangerous yes but I think
this is going to be the last game of the
three minutes section so I just tell one
tell another pun as if you need an
excuse to so why did that Queen divorce
with the king tell me because he kept
exchanging Queens I have to learn to
stop letting you okay Kings on f6 so hey
I have a question for you that's not a
pun you ready yeah why is the black king
on f6 in this position
and she takes five rookie 665 rookie six
yeah that's really that's finish Edie
Edie silver key six king of and then
Quincy Sam yeah then I take a six so you
didn't answer my question and you don't
have an answer to it because why is this
King on there it is I mean know why by
is ticking on f6 yeah oh I don't I
thought it was a pun and I was expecting
an answer no no there was no pun it was
a serious question
unlike you've it it I'm trying to talk
about Jesse no I didn't know why King is
on f6 and that hurts because now it's
plus six for international master Eric
Rosen
so it's like how much of a lead
six points six points that's a lot very
hard to recover from such a big leap
actually before the game I thought it
would be like a close match but
apparently this tilt was a big factor
nicely this is a bad move Queen effort
and now 95 is coming yep
we've heard from maxima Sheila Groff
when he's played in the speeches
Championships how Tilt happens and it
really can impact even the top players
in the world and well le pates she's
extremely strong but you could tell this
match is being so frustrated as early as
damn three when she stalemated Eric
Rosen up a queen because she pre moved
something he didn't capture her queen
and then it was a stalemate so there was
an idea for move by the range of 26 for
that was nice to just go 96 yeah men
doing the bone structure that looks like
the perfect Catalan whether you talked
about mvl and he plays in the speed
chess championship so why does MBL
always reach the finals of speed chess
championship he never does he does no no
mercy so played this year against the
car okay okay we will try to set up a
Pawnee yeah I'm glad I've learned okay
fine are you gonna say it now I mean no
of course not you ruined it yeah when
it's gone I've ruined many things that
don't stop you so 96 is questionable
decision why would you take that now I
like blacks position what would be five
of Bishop it's three how many bishops is
white have two and that's probably why
the capture on d6 happened but I agree
with you that I mean we in theory top
players you yourself you've said you
like the bishop here but in this
particular position black is so solid in
a head and development watch out for the
soft be six-foot though I believe they
used yeah you're in da da Bishop III
maybe a 5v5 you're too good yeah see
that so I don't comment on chess
sometimes so to make you feel good
you know you can have your movement oh
[Laughter]
did a bit of it might be six toss that
pony in mini suits
okay 94 good move
May 23 it's kind of sad position
actually for weight
yeah Queen play I would everyone be five
long time ago ff3
I smell tactic somewhere do you what a
tactic smell like mm-hmm
it's not a pun I don't have punch on my
sleeve I was I'm just asking in jest
we're moving on here so the doors on the
Queen side are vulnerable for black for
OC 1 9 4 5 go eat food and just crush
the position efore is probably a good
move
wasn't play 95 Queen b6 before oh yeah I
think it's now she's in one of those
monster doesn't it she's waiting for the
match to finish I like it's that's the
feeling I get the way of the games are
going
from an expression I can see that she's
really not not happy here yeah yeah
Bishop III just play that move should be
teak wing before never blinked upon and
ripping on everyone go for some kind of
compensation yeah Queen before this bed
I must admit maybe just go default and
then I can take your name e6 and get
what the III and that point III is a
Killa I hate my position no matter what
rook c7 so now Bishop III I guess
doesn't I think we should be sure III
isn't happening today
no it's not what can happen today
because the position look at the
position of the King and Bishop you've
said yes I actually let me should cheat
to at least that's a good move no but
take sticks look see it and you're still
losing the pawn right but I'd rather
lose the pond then just get checkmate in
the diagonal because I am my when
H 1 kg 180 what is a tree I I don't know
did it I really don't know she really
happened Congrats that was the point of
a tree to predict before yep
I learned that the hard way we should do
yeah Bishop d2 and 5 yep at someone with
f4 will be actually annoying for Black
Knight Judy I'm waiting like just to get
a chance to be g4 and cooking if cooking
g3 oh you want to be that kind of guy
but why we should decent I would have
taken on c1 and one Queen be one can you
take us before take on c1 the black
Bishop c6 and then I would 95 yeah but I
don't wanna lie that force 95 is she -
whoopsie - nice fit it you've led one
here and then Bishop a4 something ah a
bishop I would have picked King at 7:00
I'm taking guys out I would have played
c6 or something you know tightening duty
- yeah Sigma this is also lost she
didn't have to take on c2 that was a
mistake by her again here
here and she could have played it is on
video hopeless position well know
instead of rook takes c2 she could put
f4 and just try to play this way
like to if I were no I'm just talking
about the current version so what do you
say no I don't worry you should ignore
me I you know I know no that I didn't
mean to but I was just looking at the
position I'm proud of you for looking at
the position because normally you're the
one telling me some line that I don't
know you're talking about and this time
it was I was the one who was off into a
different variation oh gosh
just rook anywhere than 93 it's this
list doesn't matter it should be 5 here
I mean every move is good I think it was
psychological thing you know she just
didn't be chef Geter gift - yep zero one
it was I think psychological not able to
recover I think that's what cost it all
these games or maybe she's just giving a
huge lead because she knows how good she
isn't bullet we will see when we come
back because that is the end of the
three-minute portion so stay tuned
everybody let's see if Lizzie Bates can
mount a comeback in what has been a
one-sided affair on the scoreboard in
Eric Rosen's favor so we'll be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
we're coming up on the final time
segment of this match but the action
continues just tomorrow because the I am
NOT a GM speed chess champion has three
more opening round battles to happen and
that includes the marquee matchup of
round one Friday April 24th that's
tomorrow night at 6 p.m. Pacific time it
is International Master Teddy Coleman
against the one and only international
master Danny reg before that didn't I
will have the call for coach Ditka boots
key versus Lawrence tread I know a lot
of people want to see Lawrence lose that
matchup that seemed to be the vibe of
the chat but a serie so that is a great
matchup between the 8th and 9th seeds
and finally last but certainly not least
on Saturday will be charissa yep taking
on Dean Eppolito the 16 year old
international master who beat you in
June in the Karin's Cup will face the
Dean of American chess Deena bolita
exciting matchups exciting for sure and
we are about to get started with the
bullet portion with arrows and up seven
points in the match it really has not
been le Bates's day and for Eric you
know I cannot wait to ask him about that
stalemate trick that he pulled off in
the third game of the match don't want
to bring up that live what actually you
know go to seem relieved yep and let's
get off let's go let's go with the
bullet portion I'm ready for it I'm
gonna get what I'm the game started they
have not but now they have right after I
said they have not they start so boobies
I think one of the toughest to
commentate but sometimes the most
entertaining oh well you know I've done
a bullet chess championship with my day
so I get used to it you have to be like
an auctioneer speak really quickly and
hope what you're saying makes sense
right now you see the 9 to 16 pony five
right vidit right you just gotta get in
it you gotta be in it to win it my man
assured me six bitter six Queenie four
so I can always escape the night see
play your D but you don't know no it's
not so good okay likewise envision yep
simple to play co 95 yep now g5 or
Bishop g5 not
don't put any peace in g5a sacrificing
losing a piece I should say and now
tricky one but over protecting the e5
pawn
the annoying thing here is how to
actually make progress in ith - - g4 is
one big jump for directly 95 Quincy one
okay yeah no need to panic no need to
panic
you saw it though you were quick to see
how to recession you love the bishop
pair so much yes that's why the okay
I like Bishop Elias were you had to make
a pun no no no I did it okay now I am I
lost my confidence you lost your
confidence you said yes I lost my
confidence okay I'm just checking
come on make sure I'm sorry that you
lost that hopefully you regain it f4 is
coming to kick his Bishop out from g5
and start an attack on the Kings I made
with a g5 g6 just rusting the pawns on
the board I would have to do like you
know just get little cone the seventh
rank yes and the Queen could have slid
over to f8 for the defense here comes g5
in g6 and le she's up a lot of time here
the Queen on d3s can't go to f5 without
maybe which up c5 oh boy yeah she should
at least G at six why she's not even
taking G at six that was weird right
she's trying to question where the
screens gone oh yeah not much right boom
he's dreaming he's playing this
perfectly
and this is going to be sad start
useless queen g6 for sure 94 just keep
the Queen tullu clean yeah rook Ethier
played this is no fun
yeah this is really not fun how they
gonna match in this championship with
just one really down with the wild yeah
aleena cash lanskaya against Christophe
Z lucky was the final game was 12 to 11
in Elena's favor and she won the lotto
game to enthralled to 11 that was close
yes extremely it was a really well
played match probably not probably
definitely our best played match I would
say of the opening round of the I am
non-gm speed chess championship but the
actions just getting underway here this
is the fifth of eight first round
matches and this is about to be another
victory for Eric Rosen with Queen d2
check if squidgy ones meeting won by
Miami gonna continue to so maiden one on
the board I didn't miss the main one at
first I did did it I'm just trying to
make you feel better bright you missing
main ones and then I found those days
are behind me
well I wish you the best don't play
Bishop g4 here just a reminder for
people Bishop g4 that Bishop picks up
seven check so that's why you don't like
that so early lacrosse ins
DG apply go for it yeah King III when
you 1-4 disconnect I don't know even
seized it
no no he was thinking for like six
seconds that's like an eternity for
bullet c4 is something that I'm not used
to
we need one I like it yeah bring that
Queenie seafood is so weird weather yeah
with no people I agree create you mean
yeah you could good before as well
Queen each foot is nice yeah but it took
him six seconds doesn't matter look at
this like seven points it's too much oh
nice to be good I know the score I'm not
dismissing that but just in you know the
perspective playing a good bullet game
he's using a lot a lot of time and I
think that Elly is telling this one well
but she is down seven points 8 points
well with 20
one minutes the mascot and so is it like
the first upset of the lick if you
consider the seeding it could against
the first upset of the tournament yes
indeed in 95 now he's just having fun f6
f6 probably oh now that looks sad he's
your crab seller nobility 7 rookie 7 and
rookie 100 and you better fix a 5tn yeah
sv 6 there should be 6 Queen before
oh yeah she said Wendy food you're right
but I was just hoping that would work
out for me
I think Quincy to go for it doesn't
matter just plate doesn't matter if it
works or not go for it she's taken all
the pawns in position 93 I guess like
getting you know in this few seconds she
has to put more pressure yeah so okay
he's gobbling up some pawns
he may be down extremely Shui 5:57 has
to King takes t4 or Quincy for where to
try to Queens this also should be good
Queen III check and then just convert
the ending a rookie to obviously good
move queen g3 since me but watch Alec we
need to be play flick we need three
please yes yes sir thank you thank you
very much you're very welcome
Bishop c4 and just win the d5 pawn that
looks very good Bishop d3 d4 very good
yeah
yeah 96 wouldn't move bring night birth
food and now white is totally stuck 85 e
one place obscures the King around 85
heads whether it's upon this I get
nostalgic and I feel not not in a good
way I'm sorry that you're remembering
bad times here comes the a pawn a3 a2 a1
can't stop me but look as each bond - no
I didn't take it no more fun please h7
is between afraid please no oh my gosh
96 you go put the keep it inside
a full checkpoint F whoa check check
you're getting but 907 F for you saw
that for oh you're getting so nervous
yeah I just don't like unnecessary
unnecessary trouble right and now she
still limit don't get stained with it
please no still me we've already seen
that happen designs thank you thank you
having
yes and that was you know just an odd
okay you got me in that one that route
63 move with the eight pawns running
free was a good tactical idea and we
have there was like a match between Duda
and blue shoot and dude that was like
three points down in the bullet section
and then he won like three games in a
row like almost the last three games and
then you know on the fourth game and he
made a comeback yep so it would be
interesting if it at least the match
comes close you know that would be a lot
of fun like at least close down the
distance it would be fun to see that
yeah that would be but it's a pretty big
margin right now seven points but
there's 17 plus minutes remaining that's
you went quickly a bunch of games it can
happen or if the games take a long very
unlikely
yeah really unlike you of course but so
far she keeps playing this you know just
set up here
d4 move your Knight f4 g4 fi that's what
you have to do go
okay where's that night going c4 why
would you please seafood I mean you
asking questions I don't have the answer
to g4 this is also good look at the
official on b7 totally useless and so
then why just gonna push pause on the
kingside
three g 5o g six what g6 yeah
g5 you don't have to do anything about
it
yeah G if I was bad Brooke F 1 F 4 etc
just look how fast she has been playing
by the way she was 54 seconds well she
you know a draw and loss of the same
thing so she just has to play very
quickly and win the game that's all you
said Queen f6 will be a really annoying
move by the way okay she took and I work
f1 and pile of pressure on f7 but it's
not over it's far from it how do you
actually make progress here
mm good question maybe bisexual yes
Bishop e3 King g3 and sac the bishop on
g5 that looks ridiculous why troop
little give 6 for sure Brooke f6 network
f6
yeah you add flavor keV 6 rook up 6 okay
now he got now you got the hang of it
now you've got the hang of it how do you
do it oh you know g6 bishop g6 go go oh
this is so nice to release later it
Bishop d6 is amazing
please play Bishop to say she's thinking
recap to nabeshin
know it will be threefold repetition if
you do it - all right said no I told you
and so frustrated I'm so frustrated
oh man oh man wow I just I I wish I knew
to say
yeah bit of you ready to say bleep we
ship g6 to sit beside g6 hey Vitter am I
gonna get you to listen to saddleman
later so you work you read what's on my
t-shirt it's a settlement it's a band
there very good no I don't mean I'm
gonna get you to listen to them later
I'm ascending the Monza awesome you know
they're everywhere you can find them in
the normal channels but saddleman that's
the good stuff so I'm just trying to
think of things that make me happy
because this match has been hard to
witness honestly yes I need to really
watch something why it has a very good
position yes
so let me probably lost ok 666 go for
tactics now recap 3 is better
Oh Bishop at 6 oh and he's going 40
means white this game new bishop no no
nine eight six one zero six one zero
yes benighted six 986 just that tactic
yeah okay fine
Titans thanks see these moments he's
finding these tactical shots and it's
easier to do it although like me ended
up on the score yeah when you open
school yeah well that ended that game
check to the King force the corner of a
cafe was hanging with me and this is
what's tough is when you're playing
these matches and you can't just resign
you keep going even though yeah match
for is so lopsided yeah I'm very
surprised by this match score though yes
yes I agree with you it's it's been a
crazy match to be honest like so many
ups and downs yes I think I think one of
the highest at least it's more ups and
downs than the match with Tonya which I
commented earlier I think there it was
more clear
indeed and there's pie of the pressure
now on this night and f3 Bishop g5 for
instance for white would have kicked it
out it should be 5 also bringing the
bishops of rescue 27 Queen inch 3 I love
it you had the right idea trying to
bring the Queen over but you said Queen
d7 can't do that
ok core did neither tribe is a cheeky
move with you you would try something
like that there it is if you take on h5
Queen h3 comes in and then you've to
stop meat on Jesus but he does go for it
and you know Bishop g5 Knight the food
that was even like this pig number 2
trick number to keep in 95 here
95 95 - which 3 on 93 whoops night
1 oh my gosh the worst night I've ever
seen any night on g3 still better than
on h1
oh my gosh then they can't move
ah that hurts to look at King age too
but King age to Bishop e2 rook you
assure me - no not Bishop g2 the king is
still minted oh my gosh oh I mean what
is this configuration g6g 600 G -
doesn't matter
everything is lost it hurts to look at
yep
Quino Quino 3play elevator 3 is
excellent it's a draw
I don't know what to save it it yeah so
rookie 5friends is bringing that rook
into the attack okay this is
at least an ambitious try by a little
quite a bit of time f-for just go I mean
just gotta go yeah you have to play a
full before ever not happening you know
there it is
and now 1e5 with something we never
three black is trying to make progress
here but there's also the potential your
position collapses and the Queen sides
are like what is it oh c'mon I know I
again me if I go for it he 5d6
so she's pushing what's doubling on this
I I no longer have answers to your
questions
mmm me neither
okay so II six let's say what now the
Queen on f6 e 7f one brother one look
everyone there's a problem with this
Queen and the rook on h4
okay so means rook 67
take the bow and you take cookie search
for no I don't trade points you don't
have seven did it matter ideas I really
am
yeah I am me two men me too man I have
no yeah yeah yeah I feel exhausted for
somebody's and I don't know why it's
ready to but I think there's the the
emotional way yeah the emotional you
watching this match what
well I guess he is a move right because
if you play nineteen get six can get six
is hard it but is it King e6 to move
king of sixes give chief a terrible 5500
75 is nice but queen of sleaze mate yeah
but Bishop g5 is cooler
Oh
25 25 Bishop g5 mm-hmm I can watch it
he's not repeating yeah he's trying to
show who's the boss not not cool the
Sasse not yeah he did us a she did sorry
when she always always repeat right
what is Bishop of the discoveries on
this game
yeah but Queen defy Bishop defaults
finish on the sport some people you know
they don't see every single tactic other
people are you anyways the kicking on b6
there is no hope
yeah the King on d6 doesn't look very
safe
I must admit well mister vidit Gujrati
Oh Queen f6 me Queen f6 me I wouldn't
see that if I'm Eric I'm not seeing that
it's too hard oh you're joking right he
found it I mean Queen f6 of all the
checkmates that's not the square you
expect to checkmate your poem ah you
look at night discoveries of the d5
square and then it worked so we're back
in this ninja Larson and okay don't
think 1 g7 but now that's a threat
Knight f6 yeah yep and then just
developer white how do you would you
click wait no
yeah so mr. vidit yeah let's talk about
that daily question a little bit because
you know the question was if streaming
is as a negative or positive effect on
the quality of your chest you adjusted
really well in the recent title Tuesday
you kicked my butt on stream in bullet
chess and in our blitz and bullet match
the other day as well no surprise you
are the stronger player between us but
you know what is streaming been like for
you because usually you're competing in
high-level events and traveling around
the world playing chess now you have
more downtime on your hands because of
this unfortunate pandemic you're
streaming you're still playing very
strong players on the Internet what's it
like for you I would say like you know
from my experience I've been streaming
for like seven eight days all the people
who have come to watch have been just
extremely supportive and sweet yeah so
the big shout out to everyone who is
watching even now and the chess
community because they've been so
supportive I love it so I remember when
I was playing the title Tuesday like
with every good game they were like
cheering and they're just supporting so
much so I love that and I really enjoyed
that so for me the streaming experience
has been great and you know even people
are like so nice you feel good and if
you win you know it's just a very
positive experience so far and also you
know you get to catch so many moments on
camera like like some funny things
happen in Bullitt of lids like that
stalemate for example yeah it's caught
on camera when you're sleeping and that
instant reaction spontaneous reaction
all this stuff it's just exciting yeah I
love it
I saw people asking about your channel
I'd put in their video chess thank you
and if I was taking you just became a
partner right
I became an affiliate thanks to after
stream like still a couple of more hours
to become a partner but I have not
become affiliate because I have to do
some
and the link is not working something
like that but I think it should be done
a few soon and what's your what are your
plans for a streaming like in the
upcoming weeks or days
oh my plan is to actually almost scream
daily I'll play probably the Asian sorry
the world nations cup I think that's
what gets Paul yeah from 5th May so
until then I'll scream and practice some
blitz a bullet I'm planning to have more
matches like you join maybe with I had
with re-enter yesterday some bullets so
I invite more grandmasters on my stream
and maybe we can have a rematch if you
are up for it
someday and that will be fun there's a
nice tactic by the way I just might take
c2 because if the rook takes on c2 or
the Jeep on Queens but yeah of course
I'd be up for it and this you know fear
Nations Cup which chest comm is also
hosting many many strong grandmasters in
the field so how are you preparing for
it's a rapid event if I'm not mistaken
you know it is 25 plus 10 it's 25 plus
10 and it will be different than black
with like usually online it's 15 plus 10
or 10 plus 10 and proteus League so 25
plus 10 is already more serious you know
so I need working like you know doing
the usual stuff techno things and stuff
like that also the teams are extremely
strong I mean if you see the lineup
everybody's like 27 + 20 cent under plus
it will be a very strong tournament so
I'm laughing
now but you know I could be on the other
end if I don't work so I have to work
and stop like you know my pong game and
go for chest we've been asking the
players in pre and post match interview
about their preparation for these
matches you know sorry
is it like he didn't even like eight
games nine games in a row
there's no because because she's one
half in the bullet portions of okay but
wait night of four but yeah before
Bishop c4 that's actually yeah
I did it so you know we asked the
players how they prepare for these
matches how are you preparing for this
fee nation's Cup because you know is our
chess calm right it's an online event
but it's super serious in the sense that
the your opposition on the other team
includes the very best players in the
world
Cara Nakamura is playing next in Villa
grub on the pond the she Levon Aronian
like I mean how do you prepare for the
various opponents that you might face
well I think when your traditional dude
you have to really work on all X that
plays a main part and all the top let's
do that
but one of the things which I'm doing
differently than other tournaments is
play more on chess or form to really get
used to the interface
you know Mouse kills like when you get
down on time it's very different to have
like ten seconds over the board and ten
seconds on line it feels a lot more
online but other would in 10 seconds you
panic right so you know you work on your
opening that sounds like you don't need
to work on your bullet skills if you ask
me because I saw those first hand and
are you nervous at all be honest no was
forward for the tournament not really
not really it's more it's a fun
tournament like it I look at it more
like an exciting opportunity than now I
I like tell so the timing is great
because looking whenever the tournaments
begin it usually starts in Indian time
like 10 o'clock now now it's like me
past midnight it's 1:00 a.m. in India
you know the timing just works fine will
be in the evening so I just have to play
well that's all okay I like it you seem
confident you seem ready but you're also
taking it very seriously and will be
because opposition is really strong so
it's like no walk Borya right you're not
playing patience what you're saying
so you actually have strong opposition
do you take seriously yeah all the blitz
experts like MVL nappa all of these guys
are gonna play so it can be very tough
Konami and one of the things is very
cool it's an team event and it'll be
like India versus Europe so I love that
like the you're rooting for some pin for
spends also I think it's very exciting
that way is it is because then we think
it's more exciting to watch team events
yeah I think it's great but that's sort
of where I was also going to ask is does
that put more pressure on you because
you're representing your country and
you're also on a team so if you lose the
game it's not just you're lost it
couldn't make the team lose the matchup
does that feel like additional pressure
I mean of course if you lose and you it
kind of it can happen but no point of
worrying about it it's not in your
control so and also you said what are
your plans I'm thinking like after my
games probably I'll come on my channel
and like you know explain the games do
some small commentary on that something
like that that could be exciting I think
the fans would love that and we are in
our final game of the match so if this
is a game this is the final game we've
been able to hear your thoughts so we
appreciate that of course and well after
this game concludes and we take our
short break we will bring the players
back on for an interview just to hear
their thoughts and well I'm sure one of
the players is very happy into the
matches oh well oh they're happy two
matches over four very different yes
that's yes rook G for work G to Bishop
g6 checkmate watch out for stalemate
tricks though can you try just give up
your Bishop Bishop g3 Oh
check me on the board and Elly Pitts
wins the final game of this match
Eric Rosen has won by a huge margin of
10 points we will return in just a few
with an interview with the players hear
their thoughts and wrap up this show
stay tuned everybody we will be right
back
[Music]
you
Elian Eric thank you so much for joining
us and for that match congratulations to
you Eric and Ellie I'm sorry we have to
start with you do you feel like you
really lost that match in the third game
when Eric swindle that stalemate well to
be honest actually like when I'm playing
plaits and I'm a queen down I'm always
resigning and actually I was so
irritated that my opponent definitely
didn't resign but I'm not used to play
like kind of online chefs so for me like
always it's very usual to resign and
then I was there it advice I'm not
resigning and I think by this sort I was
so much irritated that I just plundered
it in a way and I mean like I'm not an
online player at all and just like for
me it is so unusual in a way that okay
when I whenever I was a queen down or
something for me it wasn't most normal
thing to resign because I didn't even
see that there is a chance but obviously
this is the wrong thing
probably in online chess you should play
until the end that's what I learned from
this match and I got quite much
irritated by this but I think now I mean
like since I saw how much games
Eric won or safe this way probably I
should have depth this kind of thing
because it's actually a smart move to
play to land
yeah Eric on your end is that sort of
your philosophy never resign um of
course there's situations where
resigning is is acceptable but I mean
growing up my my coach Howie rule for me
just never resigned and it's amazing
like how me any games can be saved when
the opponent thinks that it should just
be over and then yeah all it takes is
one peerless mistake so I've had my
share of these sort of comebacks I've
been on both both ends of it too so
that's part of the game yeah so do you
think the match went away from you
because it was two and a half to enhance
ending was a piece up Oh like with his
c64 and she explained that what's the
final cut when actually I lost the match
the stalemate was still okay but then
actually after this match it was over
for me psychologically it must be really
tough to like play off
that no but I mean like I understood
like even if I'm winning in almost all
the games whose 5 past 1 it doesn't help
because at the end I'm floundering so
what can I do right and Eric you know
you were finding some really interesting
defensive resources there is that
something you are able to work on or
just it just happen in the flow of the
game you have a bad position as you said
you grew up never resigning always
fighting to the very end
yeah I think I'm just used to getting
bad positions I'm trying to defend off
attacks as my style kind of growing up
to be a lot more disconcerted and my
coach I had many coaches going up hooda
schooled me for being too too defensive
so I guess it's one of those things that
I got more experience with but yeah
incredible how many how many positions I
was on the defensive and I mean a lot of
the games come down to these knees time
scramble situations where yeah anything
can happen
right and early on your end you were up
on the clock in many of the games was
that a concerted effort to just play
assume it quickly or did it just happen
kind of the match went that way so you
were moving quickly and when I was
winning the first game and suddenly I
was down on seconds I understood that I
cannot handle the the mouse yeah to play
with one second increment is not for me
enough like to handle it and that's why
I decided to play faster because I knew
that I would black myself if I don't do
that it was okay I'm not an Internet
player I hardly play any games and I
understand whatever Mouse you have it
doesn't I can't make a move with him
like less than one second and it does a
reason why it's hard to play fast
because I understood at least I need at
least 20 seconds to make them if I don't
have that I will not make it in time as
some pasa
there any more questions for the players
no not really it was very entertaining
and some of the games really caught us
on the edge of our seats so thanks for
that I mean you're still too young to
croak right here'll I think you'll be
fine
well I do have one final question it's
for you Eric and the next round you move
on to face Alena cash once kaya do you
have have you learned something from
this match that you're gonna try to
apply to the next one and what do you
think a plank player like Elina yeah
obviously I'm not too familiar with
Alena the first time I I saw her play
was this epic match against chess
explained and it was it was crazy to
watch so as far as what I learned from
this match I mean I think time
management is is very important and I
mean especially getting used to playing
on the 1 second increments it's very
strange because on one hand yeah you
want to you want to stay ahead on time
but you also have to play good moves
because I mean a loss position is Lisa a
very loss position is it's hard to say
if so yeah see what happens but it
should be should be an interesting
fights yeah well thank you to you both
for entertaining the fans for taking on
this tournament and Ellie I'm sorry that
the result went this way Eric
congratulations and best of skill in the
next round thanks so much
well we just saw a what turned out to be
a lopsided matched the games did not
really go Ellie it's his way despite
playing some very good chess in the
early stages things went wrong she went
out tilt then the match ends heavily in
air of Rosen's favor and he moves on to
play Alena cash lanskaya and vidit let
me ask you
based on Elena's play in the opening
round the tough match against Christophe
sawaki and Eric's play in this match
what are your expectations in that
second round battle I mean to be honest
I didn't follow all the games of
like yesterday's match but I did few
games and I know that early now she's an
extremely solid player like it'll be a
very close match I feel but one of the
things was like Eric is very tricky I
saw today like so many saved so many
swindles I would say yeah one of the
things which Eric could improve is of
course the time management he was
getting low in many of the games but
yeah it's really hard to pick a favorite
now I would say yeah Elina and has
proven herself over the board where she
drew a nice giri and Vladimir Kramnik
the 2018 Isle of Man International her
husband rat US envoy a check so you
stole the show by winning the whole
thing but her performance had many
people mesmerized including myself I saw
her crush Sam 7 in the final round and
have extremely good results against some
elite players so that matcha will be
interesting Eric Rosen has proven to be
a tenacious defender who even in the
worst of terrible positions still
survived and that is a very important
skill set to have it's not even luck it
is really skill to be able to play out
junior to the grand do you remember like
the game we're in this to match where
white lady freakin jutsu and there was
this row catch one mate ideas yep and
then he found this Queen B 3 Queen a4
like he's very resilient when it comes
to those kind of tactics so that's
definitely it's plus point for sure and
well we do have a few more matches
before that second round takes place
including tomorrow there you will be
with me on the call in the well in my
early afternoon with coach kabuki taking
on Lawrence 28 9 seed matchup and of
course the marquee matchup of the first
round the one that everybody around the
world is waiting for his daily reg will
have to keep his mouth shut and we'll
have to let his moves through the
talking against one of my best friends
in the world international master Teddy
Coleman I will have the call at night
with Daniel neared its key so it's gonna
be a fun day for me with having both you
and Don Yin join me for those in him
with that coming up well we have
tomorrow's matchup first so I will ask
you for your predictions in the Teddy
versus Dany matchup but I will ask you
to study their games
I want some super GM insight into who
has the upper hand in that one so did
any final thoughts about the match we
just saw or anything you want to talk
about you wanna shout the fans I know
you loved it the fans across the yeah
they were awesome like I was checking
the chat and I saw so many compliments
throughout and I loved it like they're
being so supportive so I knew to twitch
and I didn't expect that it would be so
awesome so love that and thanks to you
for being such a good co-host as usual
oh well you know you're being kind to me
now the puns are out the window and it's
just your true feelings are being known
but I want to thank you again for
joining me for this call I would I think
everybody who's still with us David
who's with us throughout the show we
really appreciate your support these
events are hosted by chest comm there
will be many more as we come back
tomorrow for the action so stay tuned
for more chess be safe stay healthy and
enjoy your Thursday wherever you are
thank you so much everybody
[Music]
you